- Boys, America, America, America.
(mid tempo music)
- What's up freedom fighters?
Welcome to "America
and Trash Taste", baby.
I'm freedom fighter one with
freedom fighters two and three.
- This is not even the right accent
for where we're at.
- In America.
- We're in LA.
We're in LA, Joey.
- Oh my fucking God guys,
welcome back to "Trash Taste".
This is the best show
on the fucking internet.
- This ain't my mans.
Guys, this is not our mans right now.
- What, come on, you are.
I am your, mans.
- Not when you do that.
- [Joey] What the fuck?
- I had to set the scene,
'cause we're once again in
a different place entirely.
We're not in the UK anymore.
We're in the United States of America now.
- But you truly had the Karen accent.
You are truly now cosplaying
your Karen form aren't you?
- Call the manager right now.
I need to speak with her.
But yeah, we're in LA in
this beautiful Airbnb.
The most grandiose our
set has ever looked.
- Is it?
- These couches are pretty
fucking nice to be honest.
- These couches are comfy,
a bit too comfortable,
'cause I'm just sinking back in.
- I'm definitely sinking back in.
- I gotta fucking talk and be aware
and I'm just like, "Oh Joey,
Joey, you fucking talk."
- I was thinking about
I have to hold my mic
'cause it just keeps moving.
So I have to do that.
- Every podcaster ever
fucks with their mic.
They go, "If I go one
second without touch my mic
"on a podcast, I'm gonna cry."
- I'll double fist like
Lady B did in "Cry".
Yeah, double clutch it like Lady B did.
- But yeah, we've made it to Los Angeles.
- And we've somehow been
able to build a studio
despite a lot of issues
that we've been through.
- We're gonna get into that very quickly.
I'm sure the rounds have already been made
of the actual situation.
- The rounds have already been made.
People online-
- I mean, if you been
on Reddit, maybe you're aware of this.
If not, which our big
portion of audience isn't-
- Hey Paul, the sub Reddit.
- Yeah, so our baggage containing,
Meilyne said it was
$30,000 worth of equipment
is actually I think closer to 50,000.
- Yeah, it's closer to 50.
- Yeah, closer to $50,000
worth of filming equipment,
all our mics, all our cameras
were lost on the way here
and at this moment we
still dunno where they are.
- So we had to scramble to
get all of this equipment
so that we can actually film some episodes
especially because we're
gonna get guests on eventually
as well from next episode.
Yeah, so it's just stressful as shit.
- This was not the start that we wanted.
I'm so thankful that we
scheduled in two, three days
of just no guests, no filming
anything because if we thought
that we were gonna hit the ground running,
we would've been fucked,
absolutely fucked.
- Our guest literally
arrives and it's like,
"So where's the set?"
And we're like "Ah, yeah, about
that, it doesn't exist yet."
- Do you wanna explain your process
of going to the airport.
- So I was in charge
of bringing all of the
equipment to America
'cause these boys flew a bit early.
So I get to Heathrow Airport terminal two,
and already, alarm bells were ringing
'cause I get there and I want to check in
and I can't check in.
And I hear one of the operators say,
"Oh no, we can't check anyone in right now
"'cause there is a queue
downstairs of about 200 bags
"and no one can check in right now."
So I'm like, "That's pretty bad.
"That's a bad omen right there."
- Yeah, that's worrying.
- Yeah, so I arrive an hour,
no, two hours before my flight
as that's what they recommend.
So I have to wait an hour
just to check in my bags,
just to check in my bags
and that's true for pretty
much everyone on the plane.
So I check in my bags an
hour before our flight
and then I check in my normal bags.
And then we have two massive
Pelican cases containing all
of our filming equipment.
And they look at that and they're like,
"We can't check that in here.
"You're gonna have to go to
the oversized luggage section."
I'm like, "Oh no, oh no."
- This is scary already.
- My spidey senses were tingling.
I was like, "Something
is going to go wrong."
And so I bring over the
two Pelican cases over
to the oversized luggage place.
And so there's an operator there.
And you could tell this
operator, he was fucking done.
He does not give a-
- He's probably been dealing
with this for a few days.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, he does
not give a shit at all.
And then he looks at the
Pelican cases and he is like,
"All right, just put
them on the conveyor belt
"and I'll get it through the system."
And then I put it on the conveyor belt.
He presses a button to open a shutter
to get it through the airport.
The shutter doesn't open and
he presses again, doesn't open.
And I'm like, "Okay, something
weird is going on here.
"Is this a malfunction or something?"
And he sits there.
He sits down and he sits there
for five minutes doing nothing,
doing nothing.
- [Joey] What?
- He just sits there for five minutes.
- Not even pretend to work?
- Yeah, yeah just doesn't
even pretend to work.
He just sits down and plays on his phone.
And then while I'm waiting,
a queue starts to form behind me.
First it's one person,
then it's two people,
then it's three people and
it really starts to build up.
And so after about 10 minutes
of just sitting down doing nothing,
the guy just tries to press
it again, doesn't work
and then finally, he phones.
He tries to phone someone.
He tries to do something about it.
And so he phones the operator in charge
of whoever is in charge of the baggage.
And he says, "Oh, the shutter won't open."
And then they say,
"Yeah, we're not letting
any bags in right now
"because we are just completely full.
"We cannot take anymore bags
into our system.
- What the fuck happens?
- And so I was waiting
for about 20 minutes.
And so I was waiting in this queue
for about 20 minutes before
he presses the button
and the shutter finally opens
and the fucking bags finally went through.
And I remember by the
time my bags went through,
it was half an hour before my flight.
And I remember thinking,
finally, the shutter is open,
bag goes through and
then the shutter close.
And there was just this moment of,
"I'm never gonna see them again am I?"
I had a feeling, I had a feeling.
- Self-fulfilling prophecy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, had a fucking vision.
It closed and I'm just like,
"I have a bad feeling about
this, like fucking OB one."
And I remember texting
the group being like,
"Guys, not to be alarmed,
"but I'm pretty sure there's a good chance
"that maybe we won't get
to see our equipment."
But I was hoping outta hope.
And so I check in, we go through.
So I flew Aer Lingus.
So the Aer Lingus flight
goes from Heathrow to Dublin
and then Dublin to America, LAX.
And so the flight
from Heathrow to Dublin was
actually on time, which I think
that's the reason our
bags didn't get delivered
because it was on time.
And we woke up the next
day and we found out
that there's an image on screen
with all of the bags
that are stuck in
Heathrow terminal two now.
It's a fucking sea of bags.
Our bag is somewhere
in there at this point.
But then after that,
I check in to my second
flight to go to America,
and we all check in.
I'm sitting in my seat
and then you know where you
have some of those flights
where for some reason, the
plane just doesn't move?
- Yeah.
- So we were sitting
there for a full on hour.
So we were sitting there
for a full hour trying
to figure out what's going on?
Are we actually gonna take off?
And then after an hour,
the operator comes in
and was like, "Guys, I know
you've been waiting a while,
"that's because there's
been a massive queue
"on the runway right now.
"So we're gonna be a bit delayed
"and I'm gonna be real with you,
"it's looking like that
we're gonna be sitting here
"for another two hours."
And you know when bad news gets announced
and you just feel the air just drop?
- Yeah.
- There was that fucking grown noise
that just distributed throughout
the entire fucking plane.
And everyone's just like, "What the fuck?"
So we all start getting out our phones
and everything like that.
And I was thankful
'cause I got to catch up
with fucking "Spy family".
That's what I did with my
extra two hours on the tarmac.
- It could've been worse.
- Yeah, it could've been worse.
- But after being delayed for
three hours on the tarmac,
finally I get to go to LAX.
Fucking brilliant, I finally
get to go my flight to America.
The flight itself was very, very pleasant.
We had some very good,
what are they called,
air stewardesses there.
- Service?
- Yeah, service,
we had very good service.
The flight itself was great,
but then the nightmare
continued when I landed in LAX.
- Or just any landing at LAX.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The nightmare continued.
- Yeah, and so I get down
and I thought that I had saved time
'cause if you fly from Dublin to America,
we have pre-clearance.
If you fly from Dublin,
you don't actually need
to go through immigration in America.
- That's very fucking good.
- Yeah, you can go through
immigration in Dublin
so it's treated as a domestic flight.
So I'm like, "Great."
I can just pick my bags and
get the fuck out of there.
And so I walk for what
feels like 20 minutes
to get to my baggage collection.
- Yeah, it was pretty fucking long.
- Yeah, we all had to do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
and by the time I get there,
our bags aren't even on the carousel
because they are so busy.
The people from the previous flights
are still getting their
bags from this carousel
'cause there's only one carousel
in the domestic terminal.
People from Hawaii,
which was the flight
before were still waiting
for their bags to come out.
So we couldn't get our bags
before the passengers from Hawaii
to completely get their bags out.
So I was waiting for about an hour
before we even got any bags
from our flights to come out.
And then after their bags
finished getting collected,
finally our bags come out.
And it's like a drip feed.
I don't know how it was
such a slow drip feed.
Were they fucking cycling
it over one bag at a time?
- Yeah, they were dragging it
over the same journey you did.
- Yeah, so it was coming out
fucking five bags at a time.
So by the time I got some of my bags out,
I had to wait another 20, 30 minutes.
And then of course, I was
waiting for my equipment bags.
And then I wait, I wait a little longer.
I wait a little longer and they were like,
"So thank you, ladies and gentlemen,
"the Aer Lingus bag flights
"at the Aer Lingus flight
bags are now finished.
"So if you have any bags to collect,
"we've collected it in a corner."
And I was just like, "Fuck,
I did not see the bags
"that I had."
I would rather have lost my clothes
than lose the $50,000 of equipment.
And so I go to this
corner and there's a line
of about 30 people being like,
"Where the fuck is my bag?"
- Oh no.
- And so after that,
I have to queue again with
these 20, 30 people all trying
to wave their fucking
tickets to pick a form up.
And it was my first reminder
about what I can experience here
in terms of customer service
'cause I'm used to
Japanese customer service.
- You are blessed with
- Yeah, I am very blessed
with Japanese customer service
where they felt like they
will do anything they can
to help you.
Or at least, they will at
least pretend to give a shit.
At LAX, I've had two instances now
where there is not even any
pretending to give a shit
about the customer at all.
If anything, I felt guilty
for having to trouble them
for an issue with the fucking airport.
So I had to fucking fight my way through
to give them the ticket.
And this guy punching my numbers in
to this lost and found form
just could not give a shit.
He didn't give a shit so much,
we found out later that he'd
punched in the wrong numbers
to this form.
And so it was this
experience of everything
that could go wrong with
a flight did go wrong.
And it turned a already long
travel time from England
to America and added
around five to six hours
on top of that as well.
- I'm so sorry you had to go through that.
- It just ain't it, it just ain't it.
- Yeah, this ain't it.
And yeah, at this moment in time,
that's all we know about
what's happened to our bags.
I think it's still in
Heathrow if I'm gonna guess.
Hopefully, we can get our equipment back.
- But what happens if they're like,
"Oh, by the way, we delivered
it to LAX a month later."
And I'm like, "We're not in LAX anymore.
I don't know what the fuck is happening.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's just frustrating.
I wish they would tell you anything.
I think the fact the airline
leaves you completely
in the dark and doesn't
tell you, "Hey, it's here.
"It hasn't been shipped out yet
"'cause it's all backed up."
It's like, "Okay well, I could
somewhat understand that."
But when they just
fucking tell you nothing.
They're like, "Oh well no, it's in LAX."
'Cause Meilyne was calling them up
and being very angry, good Meilyne.
- Good Meilyne.
- They told Meilyne that,
"Hey, yeah, the bags have
been at LAX since June 16th."
And then he goes to LAX
again to try and get them.
- So they told us that the bags
have been delivered to LAX.
So I was just like, "I want
to go there physically.
"to pick them up."
Because we got $50,000 of equipment.
I don't wanna risk like
waiting anymore time.
So I drive to LAX and of course,
driving to LAX is a
fucking nightmare in LA
because you have to fucking fight.
- 'Cause you have to drive in LA.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so it
takes us about 40 minutes
to get to LAX.
And then I go to the section
where they told me to pick the bags up.
And I had my second experience
with LAX customer service,
which was I tried to
explain that I have tickets
to pick up my bags.
And so the woman in charge just goes,
"No, no, no, we don't have any bags
"from Aer Lingus right now."
And that's all she says.
And then she goes away.
She doesn't even give me, time's
like explain my situation.
She just fucks off.
And I'm like, "Well, what, what do I do?"
- That's annoying.
- So I phone up Meilyne
to be like, "Can I get
like the exact details
"of everything our airline said to you
"so I can explain the situation."
And so this lady goes off and
I can see her in eyesight.
She goes off to the other side of the room
and starts picking up and
messing around with some bags.
And so I talked to one of
the security guards there
to be like, "Can I call
that lady over please
"because I think she's in charge
"of the baggage system here."
And she literally picks out
her phone and phones the lady.
I can see the lady pick up
her phone and answer it.
And she's like, "Okay."
And then hangs up.
And then she continues
messing around with the bags.
I can see her in eyesight.
I see her.
- You can literally just run up to her.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so after 20 minutes of
dicking around over there.
I dunno what she's doing.
She reluctantly comes back, looks at me
and I can see the disappointment
in her face be like,
"Why the fuck are you calling me again?"
And so I'm like trying to explain,
"Yeah, I just wanted
to get more information
"and explain more of the situation
about what I've been told
"and what the situation is."
So I explain everything that
Meilyne has explained to me.
I give her the tickets and
she does a fucking eye roll.
And just (sighs).
She literally does that.
And I'm like, "Why am I
being made to feel guilty
"for trying to solve a
situation with my bags."
- That you guys created.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it made a stressful situation
10 times more stressful
because with customer
service, I don't mind
if you are not fucking Japanese level,
"Yes King, we'll do
anything we want for you.
"What do you need?"
I'll explain everything.
But at least don't make
the customer feel guilty
about bringing up,
about needing a service.
- Needing a service.
- She made me feel guilty for even trying
to explain the situation
and trying to find out more
information after driving there
for 40 minutes.
And she goes there and
she checks the details
on the fucking luggage tag and everything.
And then she comes back
and she's just like,
"There is no bags here.
"Your bags and have not been delivered.
"I dunno what the airline have told you.
"They've pretty much
just said something false
"because we've had no bags
from that airline at all."
And that almost broke
me, that almost broke me
because after driving
there for 40 minutes,
not getting my bags after being delayed,
after wasting five hours
of my time the day before,
I now had to drive back
from LAX to our studio.
And for some reason,
God just hated me on that day
because the traffic back was way worse
than the traffic there.
So it took twice the amount
of time to drive back.
And it was just, ah-
- You couldn't get a dog dude.
- Oh man, that drove my
monk experience to its limit
'cause I was up to here.
I was about to fucking explode.
- I'm surprised you didn't explode.
I think anyone else
would've fucking exploded
long before that.
I would've certainly exploded.
- Internally, I was screaming
'cause I don't wanna scream.
I don't wanna be the Karen to
the customer service manager,
but they just-
- But in situations like that,
where I think it's almost a
necessity to be a character.
- Well, no, because I didn't
wanna bring out my frustration
on the person, but also that person
was I felt bringing out her
frustrations on me, the customer
with maybe previous customers she's had.
It was just awful.
It was an awful experience.
There's no silver lining in this.
It was just an awful experience
and it's still not resolved.
So it wasn't the best first
experience touching down
in America, but yeah.
- Welcome to America.
- What do you mean you
didn't tip your bag handler
at the airport?
How dare you not give him
a 20% tip on his salary
to get your bag delivered.
- Can we fucking talk about that
'cause that's one frustration
I've had since getting here.
So obviously, because we had lost our shit
and it still hasn't been resolved,
we had to figure out ways
to get the equipment.
So we're calling up camera rental places,
we're calling up light rental places,
all that kind of stuff.
And then we realized,
oh, there's no mic stands
because we're usually attached to a table,
but that's not gonna work
with the current set we're in right now.
So we're like, "All right fuck,
"we gotta buy some mic stands."
So I'm like, "All right, I'll
just get some on Amazon."
Go on to Amazon, blah, blah, blah.
And I think, again, this
is where we're blessed
with Amazon Japan standards,
which is, it is very rare
to get something on Amazon,
no matter how small or large,
how cheap or expensive it is,
and usually 99 times out of a 100,
you'll get it the next day.
- [Garnt] Yeah, next delivery.
- It's next day delivery.
That's just normal in Japan.
So I thought It would be the same here.
They do have next day delivery,
if you would like to pay
500% more for shipping.
And I looked at it and I was like,
"Hold on, how does that work?
"So I get free shipping if it
comes on three days from now."
But if I wanted tomorrow,
I basically have to
tip Amazon 10, $15 more
to get it the next day.
- Yeah, it's about 10, $15 delivery
if you want to get your
stuff the next day,
which we are obviously blessed
with Amazon UK, Amazon Japan,
which it comes free with Prime.
You get next day delivery.
I would understand maybe
if it was kind of like,
one thing that surprised me
'cause I thought fucking Amazon started
in California, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Can we fact check that at least?
- Did Amazon start in California?
- No, it's Seattle.
- Is it Seattle?
- Oh, okay, okay.
- It was Seattle.
- It's American.
- Yeah, okay, okay, ignore that.
That's a just I made
it the fuck up moment.
- [Woman] Seattle.
- Okay, Seattle.
- Seattle.
- But I would think that with LA being one
of the fucking major cities in America,
because you get perks if
you order from say London
in the UK, I thought with LA,
with this being Hollywood and
needing a lot of equipment,
a lot of shipment and
everything like that,
I thought that they would have a service
that is more convenient.
And yeah, I was very surprised to see
that you can't get the same level
of convenience just by being in LA.
- Yeah, you literally have to pay to win.
- I mean, it's hard.
There's a lot of like
socioeconomic factors involved.
I mean already, next day shipping,
you don't really need next day shipping.
How often do you need next day shipping?
- All the time.
- No, never normally.
- No I do because usually
when I have to buy something
on Amazon, it's when I need it urgently.
And I don't have enough time
to go to the shops to get it
or perhaps, it's something
that I can't get.
- I'd like an example.
Can you gimme an example?
- Well, say for example, like
camera equipment in Japan.
It's very rare that you can go
to a big enough Yodobashi or big camera
that has the exact specific
thing that you need.
Or sometimes there are
some brands for example,
that you can't easily
access in Japanese science.
- I'd say it's very
rare that you need 100%,
you need this next day.
I bet 90% of shit you order on Amazon,
you do not need that next day.
- Well I'm sure, yeah, but the
convenience is there, right?
- Yeah, yeah it's there.
I think it's good to
have that convenience,
but I think especially in America
'cause it's just so inefficient
and everything is delivered by road.
Have you seen the videos
of the freight trains
that deliver stuff in California?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I have not.
- You have to fucking break and open.
They get robbed all the fucking time.
- Wow.
- I just think
'cause the infrastructure just isn't there
and then the next day
delivery that they do do,
it fucks up the the people who
have to actually deliver it
'cause they have to do these insane routes
to try and deliver this,
and they're pissing bottles and shit.
So a part of me is like,
"Yeah, I'd love next day delivery."
But I feel like in America it's not-
- [Joey] Feasible?
- It's sort of feasible,
and if you are doing it
something bad is happening
to someone who is delivering.
- Yeah, I guess this is
definitely me being privileged.
- It's definitely us being privileged.
- It's definitely a privileged problem.
- I sort of talk about it
'cause it's a complicated thing.
- There's a bigger underlying
issue to where, you know.
- Japan, for some reason,
people don't give a fuck
about being worked like crazy
for nine hours and being
superficial, I don't know why.
- In the UK, you get next
day delivery as well.
- You do, but in London,
it seems like it would make way more sense
to have that work in London.
But in Wales, you don't have that.
- Oh you, don't?
- Not really, I lived right next
to the Amazon warehouse in Swansea
and it was never next day delivery,
and I lived next to the
warehouse for the whole area.
I dunno, London, it makes more sense.
It's possible, there's a
lot more couriers available.
- Is there maybe a sense
of urgency towards fulfilling
customer requests maybe?
'Cause I assume in Wales,
not a lot of people are
ordering from Amazon, right?
- No, there's a lot.
- Surely in Cardiff,
surely in Cardiff.
- Maybe in Cardiff there are a lot.
But I think all the Cardiff
orders are being fulfilled
by the Swansea because
it's about an hour drive.
- 'Cause I guess that's what I thought
where I would understand
if you lived in the fucking boonies
in the middle of nowhere,
Okay, you're not gonna
get next day delivery,
but if you live in an amazing city-
- [Joey] This is LA.
- Yeah, this is LA.
- I mean you can get it,
but it's only certain items
'cause it's gotta be fulfilled by Amazon,
which means it's in
their warehouse already
and they get one of their
couriers to come and get it.
And that makes more sense.
But I don't know, the whole
fucking system here is weird.
And even in Europe, it's
not as good as Japan.
Japan works, but Japan's had
an amazing shipping network
for like forever.
- They've just sort of figured it out.
- They're so on top of everything,
that's what they care about.
- And not a single tip was necessary.
- Yeah, 'cause people here they're like,
"Bro, we've got so many issues like guns."
And then Japan's like,
"If that fucking package
doesn't fucking turn up
"when I tell it to, I'm
not voting for you."
- [Joey] Legit.
- That's what they give a fuck about.
- We've only been here a few days
and within that few days,
we can feel an entirely
complaining about America.
- This is just the complaining
about America episode.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because it's just this
endless fucking stream.
- Because America is an endless
loop of dichotomy is like,
"Okay, oh, this big
company does bad thing,
"but the reason why it's doing bad thing
"is 'cause people don't
wanna do anything else."
And it's just this fucking cycle.
- 'Cause I get it to a point
why I've experienced
such bad customer service
because they have no fucking incentive
to give a shit about their job.
And I get it,
especially dealing with
people with the airport,
you deal with the most stressed
out people in the world.
At a level, I get it
and it's kind of sad in a way,
where I see a lot of people
in customer service positions
and it feels like the only
people that you see actually care
about giving a good service
is when there is an option
to tip in that occupation.
- It's true, it is true.
- I mean, that's just what I've seen.
There are plenty of customer
service positions in America,
but only the ones that
tip with my own experience
is the ones where you really feel
that they care about the customer.
Society, right?
- We live in a society.
- Society.
- I'd love to say that, man,
dude, I would do different.
I would totally care.
I don't think I'd care.
- No, no, no.
- I think I'd be like,
"I don't fucking care."
Why would I?
It's on my bag.
- Well, especially if you're
surrounded by that environment.
It's like, you look like the weirdo
if you're the one that's caring.
- I'm sure at LAX, that woman has probably
had the most horrible
people shouting at her
and fucking just screaming
and then no repercussions.
- [Joey] Well yeah, of course.
- And can fucking walks
off, goes home and is like,
"Oh, I did nothing wrong."
- Yeah, I totally get that.
- It sucks though.
But it does suck 'cause you're like,
"Why are you taking it out on me?
I was nice to you.
- But it sucks for me 'cause
I happened to be the person
that all that fucking
frustration got taken out on.
And it just felt fucking horrible,
which is not to be given the time of day
or just to be made to feel
guilty for just trying
to resolve one issue on my end.
- Even in the UK, that's pretty rare.
I feel like there's just
a level of disappointment
and resentment that everyone has.
It doesn't really go below that.
Everyone kind of was
just kinda like, "Yeah."
- 'Cause I feel like in the UK,
you can really just like,
"Look, I'm going through a
fucking bad day right now."
There's a certain tone
especially in this kind of situations
where I feel like it's
much rarer in the UK,
from what I've seen
to see people really
have a fucking outburst.
You know what I mean?
I mean, that they will.
- Oh, I've seen plenty, I've seen plenty.
- It will definitely happen,
but it's less than what I've
seen here in America at least.
I just needed to vent a bit
because I literally
lost about in counting,
about eight hours of my time to this.
- I mean like when it's LAX,
it's triple a mental time.
You gave eight, but you lost 25.
- Time moves slow.
- I feel like I lost a year of my life
with this experience.
- I mean, I'd be miserable
if I worked at LAX.
Fucking worst airport.
- I'm miserable going through LAX,
let alone working at it.
- People were like,
"Bro, at least we're not in New York."
I'm like, "You are not fucking any better.
"What are you on about?
"You all suck.
"This is all broken.
"None of this works!"
- Yeah, so actually 'cause
we've been to LA before,
but I think this is the first time
we've had extended stay in LA.
- Yeah, the longest time
I've spent in LA in one go
is maybe five days at most.
- Yeah, and that's
always been in downtown.
And every time I talk
to a local they're
like, "Downtown really?"
That's the awful fucking sector.
- It's pretty sketch.
- Yeah, that's the sketch sector.
You'll get stabbed or shot
if you walk down the streets there,
which is something we've
definitely come close
to experiencing in
downtown LA around "AX".
But the reason we normally come to LA
is because of "AX", and
"AX" is in downtown LA.
So this is actually our first experience,
mostly outside of downtown,
but also getting a chance
to experience others.
- Actually explore Los Angeles.
- Yeah, so you guys were
here a few days before me.
How was your guys' experience so far?
Well, it was good until I got COVID.
- That's true, that's true.
- So I mean, it was good for
the first three or four days
'cause I was staying in Pasadena,
which is a relatively nicer part of LA,
at least everyone in LA
says it's a nice part of LA.
It was nice to be fair.
And then you have places like Glendale,
which is where all the
YouTubers live and stuff.
And I definitely saw a more relaxed.
I felt safer
in Pasadena and Glendale
a million times more
than in downtown LA, which is not hard
'cause downtown LA is
just "GTA" in real life.
I felt a little safer and I was like,
"Okay, I can actually
kind of walk the streets
"of Pasadena during the day
"and it feels just like a regular town."
It's like kind of nice and
there's like lots of places
to eat and it's really chill.
- I just looked like "Drake
and Josh" when I was there.
I felt like I was on an
episode of "Drake and Josh".
I don't know why.
- A little bit, yeah.
I walked past an elementary school
that looked like it was ripped
straight from "The Simpsons".
And I was like, "Oh!"
It was that point where I'm just like,
"Okay, you know what,
LA might not be as bad."
And then again,
there was just those like
just small little instances
that just made me be like,
"Mm, yeah, maybe not, maybe not."
Say, the fucking LAX situation
or the Amazon situation.
It's very nitpicking, I know,
but I think it just goes to show
how much we've been blessed in Tokyo.
- I mean, it's nitpicking
when you choose a place
to live for example,
visiting and living
is two totally different experiences
but it's a lot of little things
that will build up over time.
One thing I've really,
really missed is walking.
I've missed walking a lot
and I'm sure there are some places in LA,
which I'm sure you can walk
but I feel like a lot
of America as a whole
is just not built for walking at all.
- 'Cause I remember I was
meeting up with a friend of mine
and she lives like kind of in the middle
between Pasadena and Glendale.
So from my hotel, it was
a 20 minute walk at most.
And so we were hanging out in Pasadena,
we had lunch and shit.
And then I was like,
"Oh, let's just go back to your place
"and we'll just hang out."
And I looked on the map
and it was 20 minutes.
So I'm like, "Yeah, we can walk that.
"It's a nice day, fucking
it's the middle of the day.
"It's what, 2:00 PM in the afternoon.
"I kinda wanna have a walk."
She looked at me like
I was a fucking weirdo.
- She was like, "What are you, homeless?
"Walking, what the fuck?"
- And she's like, "We're gonna walk it?"
And I'm like,
"Don't fucking look at me like that!
"Yes, I would like to use my legs
"'cause I haven't done that
in a while since I got here."
And she was just like, "Okay."
And she kind of reluctantly followed me.
I got five minutes into this walk
and I turned a corner and I was like,
"I don't wanna go down that street."
(all laugh)
And I was like,
"Okay, I can see what
you were talking about."
Yes, it's a 20 minute walk,
but it's also 20 minutes
of my life potentially
in a lot of danger at the same time.
- It's 30 minutes when you
gotta do the Navy Seals checks
and all of that.
- Yeah, yeah, when you gotta
dodge all the homeless people.
I feel weird catching
an Uber to some place
that's five minutes away,
but you have to living here.
And I think that's one
thing that made me realize,
perhaps LA is fun to visit,
but definitely I wouldn't wanna live
here personally speaking.
- I don't know, when there's
four lanes of cars crossing,
it just feels like a fucking dice roll.
And a lot of them don't have lights.
So I'm like, "Wait, so when do I go?"
And it's just like, no,
no, you play chicken.
You cross the first two
and then you kinda wait in the middle.
- Literally the moment
you step out of the car,
you are playing with your life.
- You just playing "Frogger".
- I mean, it gets pretty fucking scary,
especially when you're in
downtown LA or any sketch places,
which there are a number of in LA.
- I dunno, I'm white.
- Yeah, you get free pass.
Because I still remember,
I was saying this to Connor the other day,
I still remember
that fucking Airbnb you
and Sydney booked the
last time we were in "AX".
And I remember,
you were having like a house party
and you sent me the
address on Google maps.
And I was like,
"Oh, sick, it's literally
just around the corner
"from our hotel."
So I was just like, "Let's
just fucking walk it."
It was a three minute walk.
And I remember we were
mostly on the main road,
cars whizzing by, a couple of people
on the streets or whatever.
And it's like, all
right cool, that's fine.
And the moment we got to your street,
it was just this dark alleyway.
And I'm like, "This can't be right."
And then from all the
way across the alleyway,
I could just hear you going, "Over here!"
And I'm like,
"You are not making me walk
down this fucking alleyway.
"Are you kidding me?"
There are two other people
in this alleyway looking sketch as fuck,
just standing around.
And I'm like,
"I'm literally about to
put my life on the line
"to go and hang out with Connor.
"All right, fuck it, let's do it."
- I remember that Airbnb 'cause inside,
it looked fucking fantastic.
- Yeah, inside was great.
- Yeah, inside was fucking fantastic.
We had a pool table and everything.
It was a nice open space.
But my God,
it was in the most sketch
area you could ever imagine.
And I felt bad whenever I
was inviting people around
to that Airbnb
'cause I remember at least you walked down
that dark alleyway
'cause our house was right at
the end of this dark alleyway.
It was an alleyway with a dead end.
So if you would like
to rank the top places
to get mugged in LA,
I'm pretty sure that was
top 10 places to get mugged
and stabbed in LA.
- [Joey] Definitely, definitely.
- And I remember I invited
Super Eyepatch Wolf John
to the apartment as well.
And I remember he gets to the same point
and all I see is a dark silhouette
'cause he's saying that he's standing
at the end of this alleyway.
I see this dark silhouette.
It's John, he's by himself.
And I go out, I see him like,
"John, over here, over here."
But I'm sure to him, he just goes,
"Oh, hello, hello, hello."
And so I remember, he sees my silhouette.
I remember he starts walking
the opposite direction,
immediately starts power
walking the opposite direction.
- He was like,
"Who's this fucking weirdo calling to me?"
- And so I have to fucking
sprint to run up to him.
And be like, "John, John it's
me, it's me, don't worry."
- And then he starts running more faster.
He was like, "Get away from me."
That was scary.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I remember a long time ago,
Connor, you were saying you
wanted to live in America.
- Yeah, I think it'd be fun for a while.
- Has that opinion changed?
- No, dude, I'd get so
much content living here.
- Okay, okay, when you
say living in America,
do you mean living in LA?
- I don't know about that.
I just feel like even you
just talk to an Uber driver,
you're like, "Great, I just
got content for a week."
Just talking about this guy,
crazy shit he said to me.
I dunno, it's a crazy
place, but I dunno know,
at some point, I'd like
to experience it more
'cause I feel like even
two weeks isn't enough.
I want experience that
awful process of signing up
for a water bill or something.
- Why?
- I don't know, I love that shit.
- Have you not already
experienced it enough in Japan?
- No, but yeah, I love going
through that mundane stuff.
Something about, I dunno,
you really feel like you're in it.
I don't know why.
There's something about that
experience I really enjoy.
- I'm good bro.
- During I'm like,
"This is awful", but after
that fact I'm like...
I'd love to be like yeah, LAX dude,
what a fucking crazy.
You know what I mean?
Just sitting down like,
"Fuck, I don't wanna go to LAX."
No one wants to go to LAX.
It's fucking awful.
- I mean, being here for a few days,
we've already got a fucking
weeks' worth of content
for "Trash Taste".
- Yeah, honestly, honestly, dude.
- Yeah, I mean you got married
and we didn't even speak about that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- We were too busy fucking
ranting about America.
- Oh yeah, I guess this
is the first podcast
since I got married, so yeah.
- [Connor] Congrats.
- [Garnt] I'm a married man now.
- Hell yeah.
- Look at that.
- Oh, silver.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, silver.
- Classy, very nice.
- So I guess now, I can ask.
I remember before the
marriage, you were just like,
"Oh yeah, is it gonna be the
"JuJutsu Kaisen" of marriages?"
- It was okay.
- Is it gonna be myth?
Is it gonna be myth?
How was your guys' experiences with it?
- It was okay.
(all laugh)
- Joey could never say anything.
He can't say anything good.
- I could have been
in my hotel room watching
"JuJutsu Kaisen",
but I had to come out.
No, no, it was fantastic.
I mean yeah, 'cause I mean,
this is what, my second
or third wedding I've been to.
- Is this your first mate's
wedding you guys have been to?
- This is my second mate's wedding.
- This is my first friend's wedding.
- But it was very different
to my first mate's wedding.
- Oh, because it was the Indian wedding.
- No, no, it was the Japanese wedding.
- Oh, okay.
- It was the very traditional
fucking invite your boss
and your colleagues
level Japanese wedding.
So actually, I'd say
this was the first time
where it was a proper
mate's wedding type thing.
I got really fucking close
to crying watching you cry though.
'Cause in my head, I was like,
"Okay, this is a really fucking momentous
"occasion for Garnt."
Obviously every wedding, very emotional,
really important day for a lot of people.
And so, I cried at my cousin's waiting
because obviously watching
a family member cry
is gonna make you cry.
But I didn't cry at my mate's wedding.
Nothing against my mate.
I just didn't.
- You're not good enough.
You don't deserve it.
- You're a mate, but you're not my boy.
But I was fully expecting that
I was gonna cry at some point
in your wedding,
but I didn't know what was
going to be the trigger.
And the trigger came very
quickly when you started crying
because there's something
about watching Garnt cry
that is really fucking sad.
- It's like seeing your
dad cry for the first time.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- This shit just doesn't happen.
- [Joey] It doesn't happen.
- [Connor] What the fuck?
- It never fucking happens.
So when you see it in
real life, it's just like,
"Oh, shit, this is gonna make me cry."
And I could tell that
I wasn't the only one
because literally fucking
70% of that room was crying
at that moment as well.
- That was like a sniffing
convention for a while.
- That was a sniffing convention.
- People told me man.
- And then I almost cried a second time
when it was that clip
where we honked it out
on the dance floor.
- There's so many
fucking wholesome moments
from that wedding.
I'm fucking glad.
I'm happy, I'm happy because I'm glad
that everyone, it was just a
happiness fucking gathering.
Everyone was just like good vibes.
Everyone was just happy.
It was good vibes.
And that was before everyone
got fucking hammered
and fucking drunk like holy fucking shit.
- Dude, some people got blasted.
- Meilyne, Meilyne, Meilyne!
I remember Meilyne.
So we had an open bar and I remember-
- Best and worst decision ever.
- Best and worst decision of my life
because I remember going up
to the bar to open the bar
and you have to put a tab down on the bar.
And I remember asking how
much is a reasonable number
to put the tab down.
And the guy says,
"We've been doing weddings for years.
"We recommend this number."
Great, and so I was like,
"Great, just in case,
"I'm gonna put double of the amount
"so that I don't have to get charged,
"so you don't have to call
me if it breaks that limit."
So I'm like, "Great."
And so how it works is that
however much you don't spend,
they'll refund you.
So about a few days after the wedding,
I give them an email to be like,
"Oh great, can I get the refund please?
"How much was not used on the tab?"
And I waited a few days
'cause it was bank holiday
or something, and then
I get an email back.
- Processing all these
fucking transactions.
- Yeah, and I get an email
back and they're like,
"Oh great, we can refund you
a grand total of one pound 40.
(Joey laughs)
- Legit, one pound 40?
- One pound 40.
- Damn.
- And I'm like, "damn."
I'm not even mad anymore.
I'm just impressed.
- You meticulously calculated that.
- But it was double the recommended amount
and you guys fucking destroyed that.
And I'm not surprised
because I've never seen
so many fucking shots
being taken in one night.
I took around seven shots
of tequila that night.
My God, Meilyne was a
fucking tequila fiend.
My God, if you went into a
five meter radius of Meilyne,
you were getting dragged
to do a shot of tequila.
I remember this one time,
I remember seeing Meilyne ask Joey
if you wanted the shot and you were like,
"No Meilyne, I hate shots."
And she fucking gave
you a fucking death grip
and just dragged you to the
bar and made you do a shot.
- She literally grabbed me by my sleeve
and was just like, "No, is not an answer."
And so I did that first shot.
So the first shot was like,
all right, you know what,
it's a wedding.
There's seven other people
doing the shot with me, fuck it.
I hate tequila so much,
but I'll do it just because I don't wanna-
- [Garnt] You're vibing, it's good vibes.
- I wanna be part of the vibe so I did it.
It was fucking horrible.
And then the second time around
was when Meilyne was like,
"No is not an answer."
And dragged me to the bar.
Again, with all the familiar faces like,
"Oh, the first time for you all?
"All right, yeah."
So I did the second shot, hated it.
And then a couple of hours
passed by and I'm like,
"Okay, Meilyne hasn't called me back yet."
And so I just when I
thought I was in the clear,
Meilyne from a distance
fucking scuttles towards me
and she was just like,
"Tequila shot, Joey?"
And I just had to go, "Fuck off."
I literally flipped a
finger and was just like,
"No, get away from me."
And I just walked off.
And Meilyne, she was just like.
- [Garnt] Fucking ran.
- Yeah, I literally ran from her
'cause I knew if I wasn't stern about it,
she would grab me by the sleeve again
because I heard from a
bunch of other people
who were way too nice to
Meilyne that they were like,
"Yeah, she made me do six shots."
And I'm like,
"That's 'cause you have
to say the hard no.
"It's not just the soft
no, it's the hard no."
- Pressure, pressure.
- Did she make you do any shots?
- I think so.
I didn't really mind though, one is fine.
- You only got to do one?
- I think Meilyne only made me do one.
- Why did she make me do three?
- I guess 'cause you were just too close
to her vicinity wise.
So I was really worried
'cause you we had food
and I was like, "This isn't enough.
"Three courses gone, really?
"Come on, I'm a six
course kind of guy minimum
"or at least gimme someone
else's course who didn't finish."
And then lo and behold,
people just start bringing out pizza.
- It was all you can eat pizza.
- It was all we can eat
like stone bake pizza.
- Yeah, I think I had
like four whole pizzas.
- I had a worrying amount of pizza.
- It was more pizza than any
doctor would ever recommend.
Even if you were carb
loading for a desert survival
for 10 weeks, you wouldn't
eat this many calories.
I dunno, every time they
brought it to me, I was like,
"Well, I can't say no.
"I mean, it's a different topping.
"I gotta try it."
- That was me with the espresso martinis.
I think I had five
espresso martinis that day
and I'm like, "Oh that's why I'm shaking."
- Yeah, so we had a station
to give out free espresso
martinis to everyone.
- Wow.
- [Joey] Wow.
- I mean, we wanted everyone
to have a good time.
- No wonder that tab was high.
- But that wasn't even on the tab.
- Oh my God.
- That was a pre-package that we paid for.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember,
I went up to the bar after
my first espresso martini
that they brought out for everyone
and I was like, "Oh, can I
get another espresso martini?"
And the dude literally
just points to the side
because there's literally
this three layered shelf
of espresso martinis.
There was 12 espresso martinis.
And I was like, "Take your pick."
And I was like, "Oh
shit, all right, cool."
I just drank three of them and
I was just fucking shaking.
- So I guess to go to the
start of my experience
of the wedding
'cause obviously you
guys' experience was very,
very different from mine.
So we had about,
I think it was only 62
people at this wedding.
So it was a fairly small wedding,
but I really, really liked
the size of the wedding
'cause it was a good amount of size.
I could keep up with pretty much everyone.
- You could interact with everyone.
- I could talk with everyone
and not feel like it was just
like a convention experience
where I was having one sentence
conversations with people,
but have proper, meaningful conversations,
which is good 'cause I just
wanted to share the good vibes
and everything like that.
But I remember like the
night before the wedding,
I was so fucking, I
dunno what the right word
to describe it was.
It was a mixture of nervous and excited
'cause it was not the bad kind of nervous.
The way I described it,
it kind of felt like you were 10 years old
and it was the day before Christmas.
And you knew, you knew you were getting
that N64 for Christmas.
You knew, that this was
the special Christmas,
where you were getting
the fucking game console.
And so I got two hours of
sleep before my wedding,
before the day of my wedding
'cause I tried to go to
sleep at a reasonable time.
So I was gonna go to sleep at around 11.
And I'm like, "Great, I'm
gonna have a reasonable amount
"of sleep before my wedding
and can be well rested."
And then like an hour passes,
two hour passes and I'm
like, "I cannot get to sleep.
"Okay, okay, if I go to sleep now,
"I'll get six hours of sleep now, now."
An hour passes, all right.
Five hours of sleep, now, now.
- That's how it always works.
- And I was just like,
"If I just go to sleep now,
"I'll wake up and I'm gonna have a wife.
"It's gonna be great."
And then it gets to about
four or five in the morning.
I'm in pure copium right now
'cause I'm just like,
"What if I just have no
sleep before my wedding?
"I can function.
"If I just stay up or not, I can function,
"that's something I can do before one
"of the most important days of my life.
"I can do that."
But before I like truly
justify it to myself, I'm like,
"Okay, let's just try something new."
So I take off all of my sheets
and take off all my blankets
and I put them on the floor.
I'm like, "Let's try
sleeping on the floor,
"on the hard floor."
And for some reason,
I don't know if there's
just these like Asian genes
or something where it just
felt like I was home again.
And I just immediately conked out.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
(Garnt laughs)
- What the fuck?
- Yeah, I dunno, I was sleeping.
- Were you reminded of your monk days,
sleeping on the temple floor?
- I don't even know, pretty likely.
It felt like I was sleeping
on a fucking futon or something.
I dunno what it was about
sleeping on the floor,
but I just immediately
conked out after sleeping
on a nice comfy bed or something.
And then yeah, we go to the wedding venue.
And of course, I was tense nervous.
It was like the feeling
of before you get in,
you start a panel where you
go on stage or something.
It's just like you know
this big thing is coming up,
but you just gotta wait
around for it to start.
- [Joey] That's the worst.
- Yeah, I was so fucking jittery.
- I know.
- Yeah, 'cause I talked to Sydney
if she was nervous for the wedding
and she was like her nerves
ended the moment she woke up
because she was so busy
before the wedding started
because she had to go do her makeup,
go do her hair and all
the bridesmaids as well.
So she was at the venue from 9:00 AM.
And I didn't need to
get there till 12 noon.
- You had the easy job.
- Yeah, and so that was just a lot of time
for just me to be alone
with my own thoughts
and be really, really fucking nervous.
And so yeah, I was really
tense, nervous, whatever,
but luckily, I had my boys with me.
I had my boys.
- The lads were there.
- The lads were there, my
hype men were there with me.
I remember going to the boys.
So to fully explain neither
of these two were my best men.
It's okay.
- Heartbreak.
- I'm sorry guys.
Only Connor was a groomsman,
but part of the reason
was it, made me realize
how long it's been since
I've planned this wedding
because me and Sydney had
planned the wedding basically
before we had moved to Japan.
And every role
or the entire wedding party
was chosen and everything.
- Before "Trash Taste".
- The wedding was going
to originally be before
"Trash taste" even started.
So it's fucking insane that
I've grown so much closer
to these two in these past two years
where when my wedding
was planned, I knew Joey,
but we'd hung out only a few times.
And we'd hung out a lot, but
I was not as close to you
as I am now.
It was so weird to have a wedding
that was planned two years ago,
where now the dynamic is
totally fucking different
and everything like that.
- I was just sitting in
the crowding, like, "Yeah!"
- So I remember,
we call everyone in to
the main ceremony hall.
So everyone starts getting
their seats and I go out
by myself and I'm like,
"Garnt, you got this,
"you got this.
"Garnt, you're gonna do
a no tear wedding run.
"There's going to be zero
crying at this wedding."
And I go out to myself just
to give myself a breather.
Me and Sydney had personal vows.
So I bring out my personal
vows and I'm rehearsing them
in my head.
I'm like, "Okay Garnt, you got this.
"Zero tears, we're not
gonna cry at this wedding
"You got this, you got this."
I read the first sentence
and I start fucking like
my jaw just starts going.
(all laugh)
And I'm like, "Oh no, oh
no, this is a bad sign.
"This is a bad sign."
And so while I'm doing
this all of my lads,
all my groomsmen come out and they see me.
And I'm like, "Guys, I'm gonna
need some hype around me.
"I'm gonna need some
fucking hype around me."
And so this was a moment
where I took a page out
of Connor's book.
I literally go full monkey mode
right outside the ceremony room.
- It works, dude.
- It works.
I was like, "You fucking got this!
"You fucking got this!"
Not realizing that everyone inside,
could you hear me just
fucking shouting by the door?
- I heard you shouting at something,
but I wasn't too sure.
I was like, "That's Garnt, right?
- People who fear the shouting type
are people who haven't tried it.
If you try it, it actually works.
If you fully commit to it, it works.
- Yeah, I mean, that time,
it really fucking worked
'cause I had so much adrenaline in my body
that I needed some way to release it.
And so I remember getting to
the ceremony room and I'm like,
"Okay, it's good.
"The shouting helped."
I'm reset and the shouting's helped.
I go to the front, I turn around,
I look at my mom's face
and just immediately,
I'm a broken man again.
My cousin told me this after the ceremony,
but he's just like,
"If there's one thing you
definitely should not do
"when you're standing up there, waiting
"is look at your mom."
It's look at your parents.
- That's true, I can understand that.
- Oh, it's a feeling I can't describe.
My dad and my mom were fucking tearing up
and I rarely see them tear up.
I dunno, what did my face look like
when I was waiting up there?
I gotta know.
- I can do a reenactment of
exactly what you were like.
You were like (exhales).
That's what you looked like.
- You're close, yeah ,
that's pretty accurate.
- Every now and then,
you'd turn and be like,
"Oh yeah, (exhales)."
(all laugh)
That's what you looked like right before.
- 'Cause there was a lovely,
what you call it, quartet?
- Yeah, quartet.
- It was lovely, killing
it, playing this music.
And every time they
were about to you know,
'cause the song ends.
They're not doing a medley.
The song finishes and then
they start the new one.
And everyone's talking,
and then the moment they finish the song,
it was like, my God.
- Yeah, everyone stops.
- It's starting.
And then they start playing the next song.
We're all waiting for Sydney to show.
And even I'm standing up here
next to Garnt, and I'm like,
"What's my fucking role?
"What do I do?
"I just wanna not fuck up.
"It's his day.
"I don't wanna do like a bit.
"I'm not here to do a bit.
"What do I do?
"I don't know."
- And then seeing you again,
it was seeing you nervous
that made everyone else
in the room nervous, being like,
"Oh shit, this is actually
finally happening and all that."
And then the quartet
stops for the final time,
and everyone was like,
"Okay, its starting."
And then Sydney walks down
and then you immediately
start breaking down.
- I expected that.
- Which I fully expected.
So I'm just like, "Oh,
here come the floodgates.
"Here it comes."
And then what stopped me was
the song you guys played.
I was just like, "Oh
my God, here it comes."
Is that "Gus' theme"?
Jen was sitting next to me and
Luna was sitting next to me
and we all looked at
each other and were like,
"That's "Gus' theme", right?"
Yeah, that's what I wanted to ask.
What made you choose that?
- Yes, Sydney walked down
the aisle to "Gus' theme".
- [Joey] Which is amazing.
- Yeah, which I knew it was coming
because I remember, it
was literally the day
that Mira passed away.
And I remember, we were at
a Netflix shoot at the day
so I didn't have proper
time to process that news.
And I remember that day,
I went back home and I put on "Gus' theme"
and I was just zoning out "Gus' theme",
fucking crying to the news
that had just got announced.
And Sydney was also listening to it,
just listening to it, seeing
me listen to it for hours.
And she's just like, "I
fucking love this song."
To me, "Gus' theme" is by far
one of the greatest tracks
in anime to ever be made.
It's such a beautiful track
and it's unfortunate that it's
been memed a lot nowadays.
So that's how people
perceive "Gus' theme",
but I remembered listening
to that on that day
that it's just such a
beautiful fucking track.
- [Joey] Oh, it's gorgeous.
- And I fucking cried to it so many times.
And so I remember Sydney
goes to me jokingly,
she turns me and she was like,
"Wouldn't it be funny if we
walked down the aisle to this?"
And I was just like, (chuckles)
"Yeah, that'd be funny."
And then we both turned to each other
and we looked at each other in the eyes
and we were just like, "But what if?"
- What are you gonna do, using
the fucking default music?
That's boring.
- And then we're like,
"Would it be cheesy?
"Would it be cheesy?"
And so we let it sink for
a while and we let it sit
for a few days.
We let it sit for a few weeks.
And then the longer we sat in it,
the more it felt like it
was just the right idea
'cause I fucking knew that
I was gonna cry listening
to "Gus' theme" seeing
Sydney down the aisle.
I'm sure if people knew we
were gonna play "Gus' theme",
that would've taken
the fuck, "Gus' theme"?
- I wish I knew beforehand
because I feel like for me,
it was the initial really?
It was that moment where I was just like,
"Wow, they're actually using "Gus' theme"?
There was a split second
where I was about to start laughing,
but then again, seeing you,
and then seeing Sydney,
I was just like, "This
is the right choice."
- 'Cause I remember Sydney was telling me
that before Sydney comes out,
all the bridesmaids walk out.
So if you are familiar with "Gus' theme",
there's the intro bit.
- Then there's the voice.
- There's the voice of guy going.
♪ Ah ah ♪
- And I remember thinking,
I see all the bridesmaids
walk out and I'm like,
"Where's Sydney, where's Sydney?"
And as soon as the fucking ah comes out,
she just appears.
And apparently behind the scenes,
Sydney's with her dad waiting to walk out
and her dad's like, "Come
on then, it's time to go."
And she's like, "No, I need
to wait for that moment."
- The right moment.
- I need to wait for that
voice before I appear.
- Oh my God.
- It was so incredibly well timed.
- It was incredibly timed.
I thought it was just fucking
God smiling down on us,
but no, Sydney was like, "No,
I'm waiting for this moment.
"I am waiting for this moment."
- You only get one shot.
Why not?
- And it fucking worked, man.
I think that's why I just
immediately started balling
'cause I hear that voice just pop off
and I see Sydney emerge.
I'm just like, "This is-"
- It's a double whammy.
- It's a fucking beautiful sight.
I cannot even begin to describe
what I felt at that moment
'cause it was literally
like a scene out of anime.
- It had the final episode vibes.
Final episode vibes, all happy endings.
- That moment that fucking voice hit,
she emerges and I'm fuck man,
I'm fucking getting teary
eyed just thinking about it.
But yeah, she walks down,
we say our vows
and we fucking stumble
through our fucking vows, man.
- You guys did pretty good.
- Did we?
- You guys were tearing up obviously,
but I think, yeah, you
guys said your vows.
- I wouldn't say stumble.
I'd say you took pauses,
but who doesn't take a dramatic pause?
- Yeah, you took your time with it.
- It's not one of our fucking sponsors,
which is (indistinct).
- Do you wanna talk
about the actual stumble,
which was the greatest
moment of this wedding.
- So obviously, everyone's sniffing.
Everyone's crying after
we've just finished
our vows together.
- Very emotional.
- It's a very emotional,
which is good vibes.
Everyone's just happy.
And so the registrar comes over
and she starts to say the official vows
that we need to repeat after her
in order to officialize our marriage.
She said my name a few times before.
So she knows how to
pronounce my name correctly
and everything like that.
And then it gets to like the
final vows where she goes-
- The most important one.
- And she goes, do you Grant, Garnt?
(all laugh)
- And everyone in the room
was like, "Yeah, she did it."
- All of the nervousness
and the emotions just fucking evaporated.
The entire room explodes and
fucking starts applauding.
- You would've thought it
was a FIFA match happening.
It was just like, "Yeah!"
- It was so fucking perfect that everyone-
- [Joey] Everyone thought it was scripted.
- Everyone thought it was scripted.
- And everyone was like, "You
made her say that, right?
"It was a bet, it was a bet."
And I'm just like, "No."
- That just makes it even better.
- Yeah, yeah and I can't remember
what I said after that happened,
but I was like, "Yeah, got him."
- Got it, she did the thing.
- She did the thing.
And I'm like, "Damn, are
you a "Trash Taste viewer
"Cause you just gave us a
year's worth of content, man."
- She's like, "This
marriage hits different."
(all laugh)
We don't say that anymore, do we?
- We don't hear that.
- We don't say that anymore.
- We gotta bring that back.
I just realized whoever said that-
- It was a wedding with attitude.
- Yeah, I mean, that
was a brilliant moment.
That was the icing on the cake.
Anyone would be pissed off if
their name got mispronounced
at their wedding, but I was just like,
"This just made the wedding
10 times more memorable
"and that moment 10 times more special."
- And I guess yeah, as you were saying,
the nerves just immediately disappeared
from you, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And the rest of the
night was just good times.
- Yeah, I did almost fuck
up, so close to fucking up
at one of the most important
moments of my life,
'cause we finished our vows.
Well, officially were husband and wife.
And then I go sit down to
sign my marriage papers.
And my marriage was a week after MCM
so the previous week,
I had just been signing
hundreds and hundreds of prints
and everything like that,
but I was signing them as Guggukaz.
And my Guggukaz signature
is very, very similar
to my real signature,
but except it spells out my real name.
And so what happens?
I sit down to sign my
marriage certificate.
I put down the G and
then I put down the, I.
- Giarnt Giarnt, maybe.
- Giarnt.
- It's Italian Garnt.
Hello, I am Giarnt.
- So it's a small line.
And luckily, I stopped
myself before I go too far,
but I get a fifth of the
way to signing Guggukaz
on my marriage certificate.
- That would've been amazing.
- You could make the A from the I, right?
Making it a vertical A.
- You can recover from that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, but
luckily I was able to recover
from that before I put down the extra G.
- Just like Sydney (indistinct).
- What if Sydney was like,
"I nearly made a big mistake.
"I nearly married the wrong person."
- I married Guggukaz.
Sydney's almost married
to fucking Guggukaz
instead of Garnt.
I might as well just put
down the fucking animes on.
- I just got a flashback.
I remember when the fucking spiel of,
"If anybody has anything to say."
Sydney was like, "Don't you
fucking dare.", to everyone.
That was good.
I liked that part.
- 'Cause we were planning beforehand
in the boys' locker room
or not the locker room,
but the changing room.
- Boys' locker room.
- The groomsmen and all
the dudes were hanging out.
We were conspired to be like,
"What if we just like,
when the pastor says,
"'If anyone objects to this wedding,
"'please say your piece
right now, whatever.'"
We were all planning, all
the boys to just stand up
and be like, "We object."
And then we just skip out
of the room with the boys.
That would've been funny.
- But then Sydney was just
like, "Don't you fucking dare!"
She verbally said that
and everyone laughed.
It was a great time.
And then yeah, it just
felt like after that,
everyone was just on such a high.
It felt like everyone was drunk.
- Drunk on happiness.
- Drunk with good vibes.
- And then alcohol.
- So double drunk.
- On top of that.
I mean, there was a lot of magical things
that happened at the wedding.
I remember, we had
some fucking excellent
photographers and videographers.
- They were great, yeah.
- They were fucking great.
And then I remember we went outside.
We started taking photos and everything
with the group photos, family photos,
and everything like that.
And then we finally have
a moment to ourselves
and Joey turns to me and he goes,
"Wouldn't be funny if we did the end
"of "Ava" congratulations
scene right now?"
I looked at Joey and I look around
and I realized, this is
a once in a lifetime.
- You have the power.
- This is literally a once
in a lifetime opportunity.
I'm like, "Joey, that's
a great fucking idea."
- We've seen it, we can do it.
- I literally gather the boys.
- You're like, "Lads, assemble."
- It was really funny because before that,
while we were taking photos,
we had separate photos,
the guys and the girls.
And, oh my God, the guys had
so much fucking testosterone
when we took our photos.
I can't wait to see them.
But I remember there was
this really funny moment
where it was like a
school playground again,
where all of the girls were
on one side of the venue
and all of the guys were on
the other side of the venue.
So it was like a school trip or something.
So luckily all of the guys
are gathered in one spot
and I gather the boys.
- Gather the boys.
- I'm like, "Boys, come here.
- You were like, "Lads, lads, lads, lads."
- We have an important mission, lads.
And at this point, people were like,
"Garnt, why are you calling us?
"We've just taken the photos."
And I'm like,
"Has everyone seen "Evangelion"?"
And immediately as soon as
I say that, everyone's like,
"King, we know what to do.
"Say no more.
"Say no more, King.
"We know exactly what to do,"
which is the beauty of having
a bunch of weebs as friends
'cause everyone's just on the same page.
I didn't even need to say what we did.
And so we filmed the
congratulations scene,
that's fucking amazing.
- Which came out amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, it came out amazing.
- Especially the edit you
did as well on Twitter
was fucking amazing.
Oh my God.
(people cheering)
(mid tempo music)
- [Guests] Congratulations (clapping)!
- Thank you all.
Yeah, so I guess going
off of that same vein,
we tried to have a traditional wedding.
- We tried.
- We tried to have a traditional wedding.
But also, we're a bunch of weebs
so even though it was fucking painful
to have this wedding be
delayed for two years,
it actually, I think came out
to be a blessing in disguise
'cause it really, really
gave me and Sydney the time
to really add a lot of little
things that were just us.
And I feel like that's the thing
that people hopefully really remember
when they think back to our wedding,
because we wanted to have
some anime references
at our wedding, of course we did,
but we didn't want a full
on fucking cosplay wedding.
- You don't want a full on weeb wedding.
- What do you mean I couldn't
be Sebastian Michaelis?
- And so we gave everyone
a postcard with a drawing
of either it was me and
Sydney in a wedding dress
in the end "Eva" end screen.
Or, it was the famous "Oreimo" one.
And I can't remember
which one you guys got.
- I got the "Eva" one.
- Oh, you got the "Eva" one?
- I don't remember.
- You don't remember.
- "Eva", "Eva".
- You guys got a lucky one.
- Why is that lucky?
- I don't know 'cause I had a
bunch of people coming to me
to be like, "You gave me
the fucking "Oreimo" one.
- D got the "Oreimo" one.
He was so pissed off.
He was like, "What the fuck?"
- But we tried to write a
nice little personal message
to everyone who attended our wedding.
And it's little touch like this
that I don't think we
would've been able to do one,
if we didn't have enough time and two,
if there was too many people there.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's true.
- Yours was nice.
Sydney just insulted me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like, "What the fuck, Sydney?
- She was pretty much
the same with everyone.
- What the fuck?
What did I do?
I turned up didn't I?
- But another thing is we wanted to try
to integrate the places we'd been to
and the cultures we lived
in as much as possible.
So we had a custom made masu box made,
which if you don't know what that is,
it's one of those sake boxes.
So we had a custom crest that we made,
which was a combination
of both of our families.
And then we gave everyone masu boxes,
which you normally drink sake out of.
- So I was excited.
I was telling everyone
at the table being like,
"Yeah, so there's this thing
"called (speaking in foreign language)
"that you use these masu boxes
for where you pour it so much
"that it overflows into the box."
And everyone was like, "Oh cool."
- And then if you know me and Sydney,
you know that we are not sake drinkers.
But I dunno why,
but there is a drink within our group,
which we are really famous for drinking
because every time we go to like a party,
someone brings crates
and crates of this stuff.
And so I announce in my speech
that we're not gonna be
toasting with champagne,
but we're gonna be toasting with Soju.
And I'd heard from several people
that Joey's face was just
like, "How dare you?"
- I've never experienced
racism at a wedding,
but I felt like my culture
was extremely appropriated.
I was like, "Really?"
For fuck's sake, I don't even like Soju.
I did it for you, Christ.
- The culture appropriation, yeah.
I had several people being like,
"Bro, Joey is pissed."
You said that.
- Okay, pissed is a strong word.
- I know, I know, I know.
- I was like, "Yeah, fuck it, whatever."
I was too much on a happy
high to give a shit.
It was the next day
where I thought about it.
I was like, "Those fuckers."
(all laugh)
How dare you?
I'm gonna take this masu box
home just because, goddam.
- Sake just tastes like ducking
foot vodka, I don't know.
- You guys just haven't had the good shit.
- I did the 100 tasting sake thing.
All of them happen to taste like shit.
- Nah, you don't have the palette for it.
- A palette of what, like
a fucking wood chipper?
- Not Japanese enough.
- I think so.
- Exactly.
- That's fire shit, sake, oh.
- I used to not like sake.
I used to think it was like paint thinner.
- Maybe when I get older
and I get more (indistinct).
- I'm much older than you.
- Maybe I just have two years to go.
- Yeah, two years.
- Ask me in two years will I like sake?
We'll find out.
- Maybe I've lived in
Japan for long enough.
I think the next thing I remember
was actually the cake cutting,
I dunno what you guys remember,
but I'm trying to think back
to all the big fucking things
that I remember about the wedding.
And so obviously it's
traditional for a wedding
that you have a cake cutting
with the bride and groom
and everyone gathers
around and take pictures
and everything like that.
And I remember Sydney cuts the cake
and then on her second slice,
she completely fucks up
and just goes diagonal
and there's footage of this.
And I fucking burst laughing saying,
"Sydney, what the fuck is that?"
But then she full on just
grabs the slice with her hand,
shoves it in my face and I'm eating it.
And then she has a bite for herself.
- [Guests] Two, one, woo!
(upbeat music)
- And obviously, everyone's laughing.
Everyone's applauding and everything.
And then I turn over to Meilyne
and I see Meilyne's mouth moving.
And she says, "Oh, blah, blah."
And I'm just like, "What?"
And I think she must be saying,
oh, your size is so cute or
something, congratulations.
I go closer to be like,
"Meilyne, what'd you say?"
And she goes, "Lick it, lick her."
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- What the fuck?
- You fucking freak.
- And I'm like, "What the fuck?"
But I'm like, "I'll do it for you Meilyne.
"I'll do it for you."
- That beats Meilyne's weird, it's weird.
- Well, did you just
do a Bucciarati on her?
- Basically, I licked the rest
of the cake off of Sydney's face.
- You got to go half cake, half makeup.
You just got a mouth full of makeup.
- She was caked with makeup.
- She was caked physically.
- Yeah, in multiple ways.
But yeah, I've heard some funny
stories about other people,
other things that have
happened around the wedding
that I wasn't involved in.
Obviously everyone was drunk.
I think one of the people
who got drunk the fastest
actually was Karen.
Did you guys see Karen at all Demon dice?
- Yeah, yeah, I did.
I was the one that noticed
that she was slouched
on the couch, just forward
slouched like this.
And I walked up to her
'cause no one was there
and I was like, "Karen, are you okay?"
And then she just turns to me, she's like.
"I fucked up, man.
"I fucked up, man."
I was like, "What happened, what happened?
"Did you get in a fight or something?
"What happened?"
She's like, "No, I had four double shots
"of whiskey before the food."
And I was like, "Why did you do that?"
(all laugh)
- Good vibes.
- Yeah, 'cause I guess she was just having
a really good time.
- I sobered up.
My bedroom was on the
third floor, no elevator.
I fucking sobered the fuck up.
Every time I had to go and
get something from my room,
I came back down fully sober.
Fuck, walking those stairs, fuck, dude.
To get my luggage up,
fucking my entire life up.
- So I was kind of comforting her,
getting her water and shit,
and then Sydney and a bunch of
other girls came to be like,
"All right, you know what?
"You can just go crash in
Sydney's room, whatever."
So that was okay.
The other one that was hilarious was Jan
because he wasn't fucking there.
(all laugh)
I was literally talking to him.
It was me and Maki and Jan,
and we were just chatting
and it was 30 minutes before the dinner.
And then Jan was like,
"Dude, I'm gonna get a nap."
And I'm like, "Jan, dinner's
in literally 30 minutes.
"We're about to go in and sit down."
And he is like, "Oh no, no, don't worry.
"I'll be back, I'll be
back, bro, don't worry."
And we never saw him again.
- Man went for cigarettes
and never came back.
- It was like the dad going
for milk and cigarettes
that was just like, "Yeah, I'll be back."
And then, and it was like
10:00 PM when I noticed.
I came out of my drunken
stupor and I was like.
"Has anyone seen Jan?"
- Yeah, I called him.
I was like, "Where the fuck are you?"
'Cause right when he was about
to leave you, I was like,
"Where you going?"
And he said, "Oh, I'm gonna go sleep."
I'm like, "Dude, dinner right now.
"Come, it's right now."
And he was just like, "No,
no, no, no, I'll be back."
I'm like, "You're not
gonna fucking be back.
"I know you.
"You're not gonna be back."
I was like, "At least eat
the dinner and then go.
"They paid for the food, eat
the food and then leave."
- Yeah, and that was
literally the last time
I saw him until now.
And I texted him I think on
the day I was about to fly out,
to LA because I just remembered.
I was like, "That was
literally the last time I saw
"and talked to Jan."
So I texted him being
like, "Are you alive?"
That is one question I've asked Jan more
than any other person I know in my life.
- 'Cause he just disappears.
- He just disappears and you
just don't know where he is.
So I was like, "Are you alive?"
- Every has that one friend.
- And he was like, "Yeah, bro."
- You were telling me
about how you saw Jan
in the most Jan place
before the wedding started.
- So it was before the wedding started
and it was Connor, myself
and I forgot who else, someone else.
Oh, it was Mudan I think.
And we were just like, let's just go get,
because dinner wasn't until 4:00 PM,
and we had gathered at midday.
So we're like,
"Well fuck, I'm gonna be starving
"throughout this reception."
So were just like,
"There's a cafe around the corner.
"Let's just go there."
And I was walking there, and
we walked past this alleyway.
And I literally did a double take.
I was like that
because Jen is standing
there full suit, sunglasses
with a cigarette in his hand,
just talking to a homeless dude.
(Garnt laughs)
And he was the most scruffy homeless dude.
He's wearing this red
bathroom with this cigarette
in his hand.
- I dunno if he was homeless.
He just dressed like fucking
what's Daniel Ratcliff
in the "Guns Akimbo",
but without the guns.
He was literally dressed like that.
- You mean the one where he's like this?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Literally that outfit, one
for one just without the guns.
- Yeah, just like no shoes,
bathrobe just with nappy hair,
with a cigarette in his hand.
And Jan is just properly
dressed up in sunglasses
with a cigarette.
And I'm just like, "Jan?"
And he looks over and he
is like, "Bro, help me."
And I'm like, "What do you mean help you?"
He's like, "Oh, sorry, my friend's here."
And then he walks over to me and I'm like,
"Do you know that guy?"
And he is like, "No."
And I'm like, "Why were you there?"
And he is like, "Because
he asked for a cigarette
"so I just gave him a cigarette.
"And then he just started talking to me
"and I couldn't leave."
And I'm like, "What do you mean?
"You can very easily leave.
"You can just be like, 'Sorry,
I have somewhere to go.'"
But because of course,
Jan is just too fucking nice and naive.
- He just sort of tries
to sweet talk everybody.
- Yeah, he's like speech 100 every time.
He's like, "Oh, thanks for saving me bro."
And I'm like, "I literally did nothing.
"I just walked past and
you were talking to a dude
"in a bathrobe."
It's the most Jan thing
I've ever seen in my life.
- Oh my God.
Another thing that fucking
cracked me up as well,
'cause Mudan flew in from
Estonia just to basically come
to this wedding.
And I felt so bad.
This was before the ceremony.
We were all getting ready
in the boys' powder room
and Mudan comes in and then Connor's like,
"Mudan, I got something for you."
(all laugh)
He reaches into his bag and
brings out the hard disc
of the previous "Trash Taste" episodes
that we had just filmed in England.
- Yeah, so I didn't
just spring this on him.
I wasn't like that.
So we recorded the "Trash
Taste" episodes in the UK.
But obviously in the UK and the US,
these episodes are normally
about 400 gigabytes total.
- We've been blessed by Japanese internet.
- There's just no internet
speed that can do it.
So it was either we ship
it to him in Estonia,
it would actually be faster
than trying to find somewhere
to upload them.
So he was coming to the wedding.
I messaged him like,
"Hey, I know this is kind of weird,
"but can I just give you the
SSD of the episodes in person?"
And he was like, "Yeah, sure."
But then obviously he was kind
of playing it up in person.
He was like, "Wow, really
making me work today?"
I was like, "Come on man, I'm
just here with this thing."
- It's like thank you for
coming all the way to England.
Here's some work.
- He specifically said, "I'm
gonna bill you for this hour."
(all laugh)
I was like, "Oh, alright, okay, whatever."
Hey, but it all turned out okay.
- Yeah, yeah. you guys
got the episode on time
and that's because Mudan
got the work at my wedding.
And to build on the Karen story,
because you saw the girls
carrying her off to her room.
So Sydney told me what happened
after they started carrying her off.
So I told you the story about my mom
at my cousin's previous wedding
where I've never seen my mom drunk before,
but I saw a sleeping dragon
awaken at my cousin's wedding.
I saw that sleeping dragon
awaken even harder this time
because apparently what
happened was Sydney was trying
to help Karen up to her room.
She feels a tap on the shoulder,
turns around, it's my mom.
And she has a beer in hand.
Sydney's trying to be polite being like,
"Oh mom, are you doing okay?
"I'm trying to get my
friend up to her room."
Karen is on Sydney's shoulder.
My mom's like, "Watch this."
And she downs the bottle of beer.
She doesn't even say do
you want me to down this?
This time, she just goes, "Watch this."
And she downs it.
- Walks away.
- Sydney's like, "Mommy,
I'm kind of busy right now."
And my mom looks at Karen and
my mom looks back at Sydney
and she goes, "I'll be back, wait here."
And apparently she tries
to go back to do it again.
And Sydney's like,
"Mom I really need to take my friend up
"to my room right now."
This time, my mom didn't
even make it to the end
of the night.
- Your mom was popping off, dude.
- Yeah, yeah, she was popping off.
You were popping off on
the fucking dance floor.
Holy fucking shit, Joey.
- I was with D and he
can dance his arse off.
And I heard the "Kaguya-sama"
opening and I was like,
"I have to pop."
- It was played?
I don't remember.
- Yeah, it did.
(upbeat music)
♪ Love is war ♪
- I was at the bar, I think.
- Because like the dance
floor was kind of weird
because there was either no one
there or everyone was there.
There was no in between.
So it was during the time
where it was me, D and
a couple of other people
and there's like a
couple of tracks playing
and then the "Kaguya-sama" theme starts
and we're just like, "Well,
we gotta dance to this."
We gotta pop off to this song.
And so I just start popping off
'cause I was stupidly drunk,
not realizing someone
is behind me filming this entire ordeal.
And so when I received
the video, I was like,
"Wow, I'm fucked right now.
"I'm so fucked."
'Cause I never dance 'cause
I can't dance for shit.
I was dancing like my life
was fucking depending on it.
- And then you went again
when "Devilman No Uta" started playing.
- And when "Devilman No
Uta" started playing,
I was like, "All right, all
right, tie is coming off.
"I'm popping off today."
(upbeat music)
- Woo!
- Yeah 'cause I remember it went in waves
'cause everyone went on the dance floor
and then everyone was
like, "Let's get a drink."
And then everyone
immediately went to the bar
and it just kept coming in waves.
But I remember the time when
everyone started to pop off
was when fucking "September" played.
(upbeat music)
And that's when the video
of me and Joey fucking hugging came about.
But I remember before that,
I remember I gave Connor the hug as well
because it was fucking "September"
and everyone was so hype.
And that was I think the hype song.
I don't know why it was "September".
- [Connor] It's a happy song.
- It's a happy song.
And also every time we used
to go to karaoke together,
that song was always the most hype song
so that's what I thought it was.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think one of the best
decisions I made with my wedding.
- Wedding planning advice.
- Here's some wedding advice,
if you are planning a
future wedding or something.
So even though there was
only 62 people at my wedding,
which is a fairly small
wedding in my eyes.
- [Joey] Small wedding.
- Small little wedding.
Wedding FOMO is a fucking thing
because I wanted to be
with everyone at all times.
I wanted to see what
was fucking popping off,
what people were talking about.
I just wanted to see what's going on
because there's only one of me
and because there's only so many hours
in this one fucking day,
you can only be at one place at a time.
I had so many regrets
because we were also
really, really fucking busy
with the photographers
getting our own wedding
photos or something.
Probably my biggest regret of the wedding
is that I didn't see everyone's
reaction to the postcards
and all the messages and stuff.
- Should've all filmed your reactions
so I could react to it later.
- 'Cause we were outside
taking wedding photography
when you guys were in.
So one of the best decisions I made
is that we had a GoPro there.
'Cause of course we did.
I learned from "Trash Taste."
I went to everyone and I was like,
"Film whatever you want.
"Just film, whatever you want."
And I've seen the footage.
It gives you such an on
the ground experience
to what everyone was doing.
We had videographers there
and so I'm very, very excited
to see what they captured on their end,
but I think it was a
totally different view
when you just have people
filming their own POVs on GoPros
'cause you got to see
like the progression.
Everyone was so well spoken,
so happy at the beginning of the wedding.
And then you go to the end
footage and it was like,
"Garnt, fucking cut, I'm
so fucking happy for you."
And yeah, it was one
of the best decisions I
think regarding my wedding
'cause I got to see so much of my wedding
that I wouldn't have got to see
if I didn't have a GoPro there.
- You got a "Trash Taste"
special outta that.
- Yeah, "Trash Taste" special.
Unfortunately you guys are
never going to see that,
but it does exist on my hard drive.
- Hell yeah.
- But yeah, like I said, fantastic day.
I know it's a cliche to say
your wedding's the happiest day
of your life, but it was.
- Top three, top three.
- No one's that jaded where they're like
"Yeah, my wedding was alright."
Of course, live it up.
'Cause before the
wedding, I was just like,
"Maybe it'll be the
happiest day of my life."
I didn't really think about it too much,
but yeah, looking back,
it was genuinely the happiest
day of my life so far.
And so I'm glad you
guys got to share that.
- Yeah, it was fucking awesome.
- I think that's the best thing
about having a wedding to me.
We had a lot of mates there
and it was just having your mates around
to experience the happiest
moment of your life
is something that I cannot put into words.
It's so fucking special.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And Joey wore trainers.
- Oh yeah, we're gonna talk about that.
- Joey got the Vessis on.
- I do, so because the wedding
was not done in London.
It was done just outside of London.
So we were in London for about a week.
I was hanging out with a
bunch of people, whatnot.
And I had forgotten
'cause originally I was
supposed to get a suit
from the suit rental place
that Garnt had organized,
but because right now in the UK and just,
I guess everywhere in the world,
it's wedding craze right now
because we're approaching
the end of the pandemic,
they were all booked up.
So Garnt messaged me a few days
before I was about to
fly out to UK being like,
"Hey, so sorry, but I wasn't
able to get your suit rental
"so you're gonna have
to bring your own suit."
And I was like, "okay, I
only have a JoJo suit."
- I mean, that's fine.
That's not a problem.
- Which was okay.
So I was like, "Whatever, I'll
just get that dry cleaned,
"wear it, whatever."
But then when I got to London
and I was sorting out
my luggage, I was like,
"Shit, I forgot to bring my suit shoes."
And so in the back of my head, I was like,
"Well, I'm in London for an entire week.
"I'll just pop over to a shoe store,
"buy some nice shoes."
I got a little bit ham in London.
I was drinking every day in London
because of course you do,
meeting up, catching up
with a bunch of people.
So the morning of the wedding
as I was taking my suit out,
I realized I don't have suit shoes.
And the only pair of
shoes I had were a Vessis
that I was wearing.
So I rocked up to the
wedding in full suit,
tie pin, belt, everything
and a pair of Vessis.
And everyone at the
wedding was giving me shit.
They were literally doing the,
"What are those?"
Fully deserved mind you,
but you know what, at
the end of the day I won
because when I got onto
that dance floor, dude,
I was fully prepared.
I was fully prepared with my Vessis.
Everyone had taken their
shoes off to dance.
I was like, "Step aside, I
got the footwear for it."
Don't do that.
Bring proper suit shoes.
- [Connor] You had one job, Joey.
- I had one job to buy suit
shoes and I did not fulfill it.
- It's making a statement
there, making a statement.
- Yeah, exactly, I was making a statement.
- But I guess wedding aside,
I guess it was a reasonable
amount of time in the UK.
I feel like you got to experience more
of the UK this time as well.
- Yeah, absolutely, I mean,
last time I was in the UK,
which was the first time
was we were staying mostly
at your place in Brighton.
So I think we were only in
London for maybe two days.
And even then, it was mostly just going
to all of the touristy places and whatnot.
So I think, yeah, this time around,
not only did I get to have a proper view
of London, London, but also
like Chris took me out of London
as well 'cause we went
filming to a bunch of places
and I actually got to see
the country side of London.
I got to see Stonehenge.
- Oh, did you actually?
- Yeah, we went to Stonehenge.
- It's really disappointing, isn't it?
- Yeah, it looks way
cooler from a distance.
So to get to Stonehenge,
you have to go to this visitor center,
buy a ticket for some fucking reason
and then you can either take a bus,
which is five minutes to Stonehenge
or you can walk across
the fields for 30 minutes.
And I was like, "Well,
it's kind of a nice day.
"Let's just walk across the fields
"'cause it might be nice."
It was not nice because
it was not only nothing
for 30 minutes,
but there was also just
horse shit everywhere.
So I'm fucking dodging this horse shit
because God forbid,
these are the only pair of
fucking shoes I have as well.
- Your Vessis, man.
- Yes, I was wearing the Vessis.
- No wonder why I smell shit.
- I was like, "No, I have to
wear these in the wedding.
"I'm not having horse shit on these."
So we got to it and then I guess
because there was like an
incident some years ago
of some drawing shit on
the Stonehenge stones
so they had actually fenced it off,
but they had fenced it off
not really an arms reach away,
but at least about a 100 meters away.
So the closest you could get
to Stonehenge was 100 meters away,
which was kind of defeating
the purpose I guess
because apparently you used to be able
to actually walk into Stonehenge
and actually get like a view of it.
You can't do that anymore
because I guess some people
just ruined it for everyone,
which was kind of underwhelming,
I guess in a sense,
but I was like, "Well, Stonehenge
is that one heritage site
"that you hear people talking about
"and it's a hot tourist place."
- [Connor] Just weird.
- So I was just like,
"Well, you know what,
"at least now I can say
that I've seen Stonehenge."
But was it fascinating necessarily?
Not really.
- I'd go to a Greggs
any day over Stonehenge.
- I mean, we did afterwards.
We went to a Greggs afterwards,
but I think the most enjoyment I had
on that trip out of London was the fact
that I just actually got to
see the real side of the UK,
the actual countryside.
We went past all these really
small, quaint little villages.
There were some villages
that we drove past
that legitimately looked like RPGs.
It was like an RPG medieval
town, which was so fucking cool.
- That's most of the UK.
- Right, but I had never seen that before
'cause my experience of the
UK is London and Brighton,
which is very much not like that.
So it was really cool to actually stop by
in these really small,
quaint villages to be like,
oh, we got like the full
experience of the UK.
One of the best fucking
stories was we stopped by.
I was dying for a piss.
And so I was like, "We
have to stop by somewhere."
But we're in the middle of nowhere.
So we're like, oh, okay,
I guess we'll just stop by
the closest village to see
if there's an establishment we can borrow.
So we stopped by this village.
I don't even remember
the name of this village.
It's fucking tiny.
And we got to the entrance of the village
and there's this old dude standing there.
And he kind of flags us down like, "Hey."
And so Chris was like, "All
right, what's what's happening?"
And we drive up to him and he is like,
"Yeah, what's, the problem."
And the guy goes, "Are you
here to see the duck race?"
And we're like, "What?"
And he's like, "There's
a duck race happening.
"So make sure
"to drive nice and slowly
across this road, okay?"
And we're like, "A duck race?"
- A duck race.
- And sure enough, we
drive maybe about 50 meters
and there's just this gathering
of about 10 to 20 old people
just watching these ducks.
- That sounds awesome.
- And I'm like,
"This is the most British
thing I've ever seen
"in fucking my life."
- What else are you gonna
do with your free time?
- Yeah and I was like, "I
wanna be there at that age."
I wanna just like wake up
in the morning and be like,
"Oh, the duck race is today."
And just go down some of my local pond
and just watch some ducks.
It was fucking awesome.
- We went to a pub the day for the wedding
and it was this very,
very quaint local pub
in this very, very small town
because where the wedding took place,
it was in a town that you could walk
from one end to the other in
about 30 minutes, I think.
- Yeah, it was fucking tiny.
- It was fucking tiny.
So it was a local pub.
And I remember there was
just this poster on the wall
that just said,
"This is the place
"for the Worldwide Annual
Pea Tossing Tournament,"
or something like that.
- Oh yeah.
- It was the Pea Flicking Tournament.
- What?
- Well, I think it's the way
that the streets had kind of
the way the natural landscape
was is that the idea was
that you threw the pea
'cause I Googled it.
I was curious.
You throw the pea.
This is gonna tell them
wherever your wedding was
by the way.
It's only in this place.
- I mean, I already have one wedding.
- So the way that this kind of town
has really cool architecture.
There's a village at the top
and then it kind of winds down
towards the bottom.
So the idea of this pea throwing thing,
apparently according to Google,
is that the idea is that you throw it
and hopefully if you throw it well enough
or you're kind of lucky,
it'll kind of bounce around the walls
and kind of go all the way down.
People will follow it
and see the furthest it goes,
which I think that's pretty fucking fun.
- That sounds fucking fun.
- It's also extremely British.
- That's really British, but that's fun.
I like that.
- This video is sponsored by Book Walker.
Guys, are you craving some good Manga
to get you through this summer heat?
- Yeah, I am.
- Well, thankfully Book
Walker has got you covered.
- As one of the most popular ebook stores
for English Manga and
light novels out there,
this summer, they're holding
an irresistible promotion
where you can get Manga,
wait for it, for free.
- For a limited time of four weeks,
Book Walker now has the first
volume of a different set
of Manga titles available on
rotation for free every week.
- Garnt, tell the lovely
audience what's on this week?
- This week, they have some banger titles
such as "Rent a girlfriend",
"The time I got reincarnated as a slime",
but also to celebrate the
beginning of the new anime season,
they have the source material
to the brand new anime series
called "The Yakuza's
guide to babysitting",
which is airing right now.
- [Connor] The first volume
of these three titles will be available
for free until July 14th PT.
But if these aren't your gem,
don't fret, there are
plenty more coming up
in the next few weeks, as you
can see on screen right now.
- So go check out the
details of this promotion
on their special learning page linked
in the description below
and add some new favorites
to your Manga collection
before this promotion ends
on July the 28th PT.
Thank you again to Book Walker.
Back to the episode.
- So you met my parents
for the first time.
- Oh yeah, that was fun.
- Connor came around
to my house a few days
before the wedding.
We had a nice meal together,
and Connor met my parents
for the first time.
- I got out of the car
and I was wearing a hat
and I met your dad.
And I was like, "Oh, hi, hi."
And he's like, "Oh hi, hi."
And I go inside and then your mom sees me.
She said, "Oh my God, it's Connor."
She was like, "I watch you all the time."
I was like, "Oh, oh yeah,
hell yeah, hell yeah."
She's just really sweet
and she gave me a hug.
And she just like,
"Oh my God, I always watch you on the TV.
"It's so nice to see you here."
- It's so wholesome.
- It was really wholesome.
And then she whipped up
the best food I'd ever had.
It was just amazing.
It was really good food.
- But there was this one moment
where I can't remember if it
was when she first met you
or when you were having food or something,
but I remember she was talking to you
and then she's never
really mentioned to me
about any of our content aside
from what we've talked about
and everything like that.
- Yeah, I remember.
- So she's never mentioned
this to me before,
but I remember she turns
to Connor and she's like,
"You should have won the cycling special."
- And I'm like, "What the fuck, mom?"
- Everyone knows that,
everyone knows that.
- What the fuck?
I was like, "I got betrayed
by my own fucking family."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- It was true.
I was so happy.
- And I was like she's never,
ever mentioned the cycling
special to me before at all
aside from, "Oh, it looks
like a really beautiful
"place you guys went to."
- Glad to know where
your mom's loyalties lie.
- Your mom is literally the
embodiment of the sovereign.
- Bro, I got fucking
betrayed, man by my own blood.
- And then I think your
dad then realized who I was
'cause he'd said hi to me, but he didn't.
And then I think when your mom
had said that, he was like,
"Oh, he's that guy."
And he was like, "Oh, it's
Connor, it's Connor, hi, hi."
And I was like, "Oh, okay, hi."
It was really nice.
It was very sweet.
- It was so cute.
- How was your experience back in England?
- Yeah, it was good.
You know how it.
It's like going back and
just like, "Hey, I'm back
"let's drink, let's do it."
It was weird seeing somethings
had changed kind of a little bit.
I don't know, it was interesting this time
'cause it was very full on this time.
Every single day, there
was something happening,
but that was good.
I like that 'cause I kind of hate it
when I'm not doing anything
and I'm like wandering around.
What am I gonna do today?
What am I gonna eat?
'Cause what am I gonna
eat is so important.
- I was actually really much happier
with the food that I had there.
- That was so fucking good.
- Yeah, I dunno if the
food quality just improved
or we just went to better restaurants.
I dunno, it felt like there
were more food options
in my trip back to England this time.
- I mean, just got
Borough Market in London,
best fucking food in London I swear.
Every restaurant there
goes unequivocally hard.
It's so fucking good.
- I spent an afternoon
in the Borough Market
with a friend of mine from high school
and it was fucking awesome.
So cool, dude, the
cheese there, to die for.
- Yeah, it's good shit, dude.
I did a livestream in London as well.
- Oh, you did it during fucking
Jubilee weekend as well.
- That looked like hell, man.
- Yeah, I was filming with
Chris at West Minister Bridge
and you couldn't move.
It was so busy 'cause everyone was waiting
because the only thing
that was happening that day
was the jets and stuff were flying over,
which was kind of cool.
The jets flew over in the formation of 70.
A stupid amount of jets.
I'm like, "Is this where
our military power is?"
Okay, never mind.
And then they did the
fucking red, white and blue,
not America, UK, all
that fucking came over.
It was just crazy.
It was just so busy.
Could not get phone signal anywhere
because it was just so
many people were there.
It was really cool.
I got a view through a shooting bridge
'cause we were stopping to
try and set up my IRL bag.
We could not get signal
anywhere to start the stream
'cause there was just so many people.
It was cool.
I was accidentally in the
right place at the right time
to see this thing happen.
And so I finally managed
to find a spot three or four miles away
from where we originally
were gonna start the stream,
where it was like, okay,
the signal is kind of okay.
Let's just fucking start it.
And my laptop is in my hotel
room connected to the internet
and I press go live and it's one megabyte.
And for Twitch, you need about six.
It can work on three to four,
but it's sketch and I had one.
And I was like, "Fuck".
And we'd already started.
We'd already spent an hour prepping.
And I was like, "Fuck."
And you know that funny thing
when your PC is connected
to wifi and internet,
for some reason it'll be like, sorry,
it was connect to wifi and ethernet.
Sometimes it's like choose the wifi.
I like the wifi.
It's kind of sick.
Wireless and it's like, no, no, no, no.
Use the fucking, why would
you use the slower one
when you connected to the fast one?
I'm sure there's some fucking
engineer in the comments
who'll be like,
"Oh, actually it's because the wifi."
And I'll be like,
"I don't fucking care."
To me, it just doesn't make sense.
So I'm remote access
with my fucking phone.
I'm like trying to zoom
in, click the wifi thing,
turn off the wifi
and then suddenly it's
all working perfectly.
We go live and we fuck around in London.
It was great.
It was really fun.
Chris was probably the
happiest I've ever seen him
in the UK.
- Bro, Chris seemed like
he was in his element.
- Bro, he was in cloud nine.
He was like, "I'm so glad to be back.
"I just wanna go to a pub.
"I wanna have fish and chips, mash pies.
"I don't fucking know."
- My man was like cleaning
up English breakfast
like it was nothing.
- I think he was doing
the English breakfast tour
of the UK.
I'm gonna try it here.
Man was unstoppable.
It was great time though.
- It was so interesting
just seeing the dichotomy
of Chris doing an IRL stream
with you in Japan versus in the UK.
In Japan, he's just like,
"Don't talk too loud.
"I don't wanna be a dickhead."
- Yeah, I feel like in Japan,
I have to be the one who's like,
"Yo, we're gonna do this.
"We're gonna do this."
And in, in the UK, Chris is like
"Let's fucking go here.
"Let's do this.
"Get outta the way poor people."
It was just so fun.
It was great, it was great.
- I'm sad I didn't get to
hang out with Chris before
because I was stacked every
day before the wedding.
- Oh, of course, obviously,
I mean you had so much shit to do.
And then you had to
entourage the American family
and show them around
and make sure they weren't in trouble.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I mean, it was a very,
very interesting experience
showing them around
'cause the first night
they'd just flown in
and so they didn't wanna go too far.
But we went to my local pub,
which is literally down the road.
So it's not in central, central Brighton.
We're on the outskirts
of Brighton, whatever.
So it's not somewhere you see
a lot of touristy people go
because Brighton's a pretty
famous touristy place.
And I remember we go
there and we sit down,
we're having a pint and
obviously they're American
and they got the true British experience.
It was a local pub and
we had local people there
and some younger people
recognized their accents.
- Oh my God.
- Were there like road men or something?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, road men.
- And I'd never seen,
there's always the image
of how Americans think
British people speak.
And for the first time,
Sydney's family got the
true British experience.
They got true local Brits.
And I remember there was this
one kid having a conversation
with Sydney's brother,
and of course, he was talking
about his fucking rap career
that was going to take off in America
'cause he had listeners from New York,
and he had a Spotify account.
And I could see Sydney's
brother's face just,
"I know you are speaking English,
"but I have no idea what
the fuck you are saying."
It was literally like a scene
now of "The Inbetweeners".
- Meilyne's husband, Maki
had the exact same experience
when I took him to a friend's house
'cause my friends in London,
they're not originally from London,
they're from further up north,
so they have the more northerner accent.
And one of my friends Yusuf,
he has a really strong Leeds accent,
which is hard even for me
to understand sometimes.
So it was just fucking hilarious
every time Yusuf opened his
mouth and just said something.
Maki would just squint like this,
like he's really trying to concentrate.
- How do I turn the subtitles on?
- He's like, "This is
definitely English I think,
"I don't know."
And every time Yusuf would stop talking,
I would turn to Maki in Japanese.
I'd be like, "Did you understand that?"
And he was like, "No."
(all laugh)
And then he got really sad.
And he was like, "I thought
I was good at English,
"but I guess I'm not."
And I'm like, "Don't
worry, don't worry, Maki.
"It's fine, even I have
trouble with this English."
- That should be on the TOEIC exam.
It should be, "Can you
understand a man from Leeds?"
If you can, you're fluent.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- You're good to go.
- It's funny 'cause the
more Northern you go,
the harder time it gets for
anyone outside of the UK
to understand what the fuck is being said
'cause even for me as like of southerner,
I can barely understand
what's being said in
Liverpool or something.
- That's why it's OP being from the north.
You just understand everyone.
It's great, I'm like, "Yeah, super chill.
"It's all good."
The only time I struggle
is I felt ashamed at this one point.
I think there's a clip of a
really, really rural Irish pub.
And then they interviewed this guy-
- Is that the guy with the three teeth?
- I think so, and he
just fucking says shit.
And even at that point, I'm like,
I haven't even understood three words.
- It's like the guy from
"Kalani" or something.
- It might be something like that,
that was the only time where I'm like,
"Yeah, I don't even know
"if the other people in
the pub understood him."
I don't know if I'm the weird one.
- But the interviewer understood him
because he's from that part of the UK.
- Oh, that's right.
- The guy would just
be like, (indistinct).
And he'd be like, "Yes,
I look this pub too."
And it's like, you're
conversing with this guy?
- I wish I understood that.
That was the only time I felt inadequate.
I was like,
"Fuck, I thought I understood
everything, everything, fuck."
- I know the exact video
you're talking about as well.
'cause I felt disappointed as well.
'Cause I'm like, "I'm sure
I can understand this.
"I'm sure I can understand this."
I don't know, you start
playing it at 0,5 speed
and you're like,
"Maybe I can like gauge the syllables."
- The closed captions just say,
"Fuck it, I don't know."
- I don't even think the
closed caption can determine
if it's English or not.
- I wish it was a TV ad one
so they have to had that woman
who does the sign language.
Just trying to do the sign
and she's like, (exhales).
- She's just like.
- I dunno, I give up.
I don't give a fuck.
- Do they have strong accent
in Wales to the point where?
- Maybe nothing you wouldn't
be able to understand.
Just the very like, "Oh,
I'm from this village.
"We talk like this."
- Is there differing
geographical differences
in Wales like the UK
or is it kind of just stronger or weaker?
- Generally, the more north west you go.
I had to fucking do
that thing with my hand.
It gets a little stronger.
The south has a different accent,
but it's not completely,
I wouldn't say it's that different,
but they also have different words.
So I feel like the difference
is not so much in the dialect,
well, not the dialect
it's a different word,
but the accent isn't as
different, just the words.
So the accent sounds
very similar with both,
but you get the more
traditional Welsh accent
that you might hear in movies
and stuff from the South.
- So it's more of a dialect difference
than a pronunciation difference.
- Yeah, the dialect's pretty similar.
- I mean, so it's basically like Japan.
- Fuck, I keep fucking up.
- So it's like Japan.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean it's
'cause the fucking history
is so different between
the north and the south
'cause the south was conquered by England
for a really long time
and the north wasn't.
So it's way more Welsh up north.
Just watch "Vinland Saga".
They lightly touch it a little bit.
- I'm jealous 'cause Australia
doesn't have that at all.
And I always thought it was really cool.
America and the UK, it's like,
oh, you can immediately
tell where someone is from,
but in Australia, we
don't have that at all.
- Yeah, I really love the history of it,
but no one gives a fuck
so it's really boring to talk about it.
And I don't wanna talk about it
if people are fucking resident
sleeping, they're like.
But "Vinland Saga" is pretty good.
- I think it's super hot.
I think it's super hot.
- It doesn't really cover it.
It's cool that it at
least touches upon it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's a fucking mess.
It's really cool though.
- At least you got an anime around it.
- You got England, but
at least we had Askeladd,
that's all that matters.
- You got one of the
most bad ass characters
in all of anime, man.
- The most representation we
got is fucking five minutes
in a "Hetalia" episode.
- You got "Ren" from "Free!".
- Yeah, oh wow.
- Bro, he's Australian.
- Literally the worst character.
- Bro, he fucking tears
it up in the water.
- To be fair, when I did
watch the "Free!" Movie
and I saw Sydney station,
I was like, "Yo."
- Fuck yes, let's go.
- Let's go!
- I think the most representation I've had
is just one guy from "Yuri!!!
On ICE", and that's it.
- What about the "K-On!" Movie?
That was set in the UK.
- I'm talking about Thailand, Thailand.
- Oh Thailand.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We had a one Thai ice
skater in "Yuri!!! On ICE"
And I remember there's a big anime chain
in Japan called like Animate.
So we have an Animate in Bangkok,
and there was just like
this one cardboard cut out
of that one Thai ice skater
from "Yuri!!! On ICE".
And it was just like, "We did it boys,
representation in anime, let's go!"
- To be fair,
he's kind of like one of the
most badass animate characters
as well so that's pretty cool.
He's definitely up there
and not because he's warped,
that might have bumped him up a few spots.
- We just got racially
profiled by "Hetalia" character
that wasn't even accurate.
And then he was in one episode
and he never came back.
- At least you got "Hetalia".
Wales didn't even get one.
- Every other country got it
except Wales apparently.
- Wales didn't get it.
They were like, what are
they fucking doing in Wales?
This is it.
Again, I've said this a billion times.
Wales has a branding problem.
The post in charge of Welsh branding,
I don't know who it is, prime minister,
I dunno, needs to fucking sort this out.
We need to have a game plan
of how we're gonna brand more.
- What's there in Wales?
- See, that's the thing.
What am I gonna tell you?
Oh, do you like history?
Great, well there's loads,
but if not, go and eat some fucking sheep.
- That's great.
- If you like lamb, it's amazing.
We also have some pretty good baked stuff.
We have a lot of Welsh
cakes, that's kinda good.
Nature, nature's really good.
- I've been to like Ireland
and I fucking love Ireland.
It's one of the most aesthetic places
I've ever been to
outside outside of Japan.
- Felix went to Wales, he loved it.
No, I think it was Abergavenny,
really cool looking place.
It was inspired by like
Mediterranean things weirdly
in the west of Wales.
It's a really cool area.
- He sold me on Wales.
- There's a lot of really cool areas.
You can't just rock up.
If you just rock up without
researching where to go,
you're gonna be like where
the fuck is everything?
- What is there to do?
- Where am I?
If you know what you're going
for some amazing hiking spots,
really beautiful nature parks.
A lot of the north Brecon Beacons area
is all nature reserves.
Nothing's built there.
Just go hike, having a great time.
- Brecon Beacons is really good.
- Yeah, Snowdonia.
- Snowdonia.
- That sounds like a place
from "Game of Thrones".
- That's like a "Pokemon".
- I mean, Chris has been up there.
Yeah, that's good.
There's a bunch of cool seaside
stuff that you can go to,
but it depends.
You really have to research.
- 'Cause when you hear about
people visiting the UK,
obviously there is England.
- Ireland, Scotland.
- People are like, "Oh I
fucking love going to Ireland."
'Cause every fifth person here in America
is apparently half Irish or some shit.
But then you also hear people
talking about Scotland.
- I think it really helps
for the UK countries.
Okay, you have London and
then you can branch out.
You have Scotland, then
you can branch out.
You got Dublin, then you can branch out.
You have Cardiff,
even then, Cardiff is really
far from all the nature stuff.
It's kind of weird in Wales
where if you wanna travel via
public transport up north,
you have to go around and back up.
You can't just go through the middle.
- 'Cause there's a lot of mountains or?
- Yeah, there's a lot of mountains
and that didn't make sense
to build the trains there
because it kind of
connects through England
and then it goes back in just
like Shrewsbury and stuff.
So if you go really far west
and it is going on, off or on,
it's kind of really
annoying to get back up.
So if you're going westward
you plan your whole trip to
go west and then you go back.
It's kind of annoying to go back up.
You can if you wanna go to Aberystwyth.
No, Aberystwyth is down south.
What am I saying?
No, Aberdare, there's so many.
It's all weird.
It's a really cool place.
If you plan your trip, it'll be cool.
- I still wanna go.
- Again, there's some amazing stuff.
- You gotta show us around
'cause I've never had a
guide for Wales basically.
- You have to bear in mind,
my experience with Wales was
when I was young and a kid.
If you are like, "Oh, show me Wales."
I'm like, "Show you Wales"
- Yeah, but I'm gonna be
like that for Australia.
- Yeah, I guess so.
- My view of Sydney is
gonna be very different
to the average tourism.
- Yeah, I think 'cause
all my tourism was done
in the confines of school trips and stuff.
So it's very warped.
What I actually would think would be fun.
My parents know though.
My parents love doing it.
They're doing this thing
where they go all around Wales by walking,
not in one go, it's in trips.
So they do a section and they go back,
and then they do another
section and they go back.
- [Joey] That's cool.
- That's fucking insane, man.
- My parents love walking and exercising.
I wish that rubbed off on me.
I've got the bare minimum of
wanting to walk and stuff.
But yeah, if you're interested
in really convoluted
and complex history, yeah,
you might wanna look into it.
It's kind of cool.
It's just about people
trying to not be taken over
by the English for 400 years
and then they fail.
- It's more history than
what we've got, dude.
- That's true.
- It's pretty much
every country in the UK.
- I think they did a pretty good job.
Look at the rest of them.
They didn't last very
long against England.
I think we did pretty good.
Oh, we had a pretty good run.
It was a pretty good run.
But I mean it's cool.
There's some pretty funny history moments.
I've told that story before
about the castle that got took over.
I fucking love that story.
It's so fucking funny.
- I wish we had fun stories like that.
We didn't have any of that shit.
A bunch of convicts were
just like, "Fuck you, UK."
And then we just started
our own country and yeah,
just a whole lot of racism
and politics happen.
- When Sydney's family were visiting,
you take for granted just
how much history the UK has
'cause I was showing them,
even them just seeing buildings,
pubs that were just really odd,
that was fascinating for them.
- Many churches in the UK
have been around since over 1,400 years.
There's been a lot of churches
that were still built in 800.
This is just insane that
they're still there.
- [Joey] It's crazy.
- We take for granted
just having a country
with history in it,
whereas I think if you're over
25 or something in America,
then you've been alive for a 10th
of the entire country's history.
Your entire country's age
and that just fucking blows my mind
that there's a country that is that young.
- But then you run into the issue of okay,
I wanna learn about UK
history, where do I start?
And then you go with the highlights,
but then when you start digging
into stuff, you're like,
this is really fucking convoluted.
So they took over, and
then another guy took over
and then another guy took over,
and then England's got
taken over by Vikings,
and then now it's the French.
- Yeah, it's convoluted, but
it's super fucking fascinating
if you're into that shit.
- That's what makes it even cooler
that some of these churches
and stuff have lasted being
taken over 10 different times.
It's like, how the fuck did this happen?
- It's the exact same thing
with Japanese history as well
and that's what makes it
so fascinating for history fanatics.
Australia's not even 250 years old.
We fucking founded 1777, I think 78.
The UK had already figured
this shit out by then.
We were just like, "Oh,
what the fuck do we do?"
- A lot of countries that we know today
and we're super used to are very new.
- I think Finland is only
like a 100 years old.
- Yeah, and Germany.
To think that Germany
was a completely different fucking thing.
That's so weird.
'Cause we've been alive our whole life.
I mean, our whole life
is like an Angela Merkel.
It's so weird when you're like,
these countries weren't a thing.
- I don't think Germany wanna
talk about their history.
- Yeah, they don't want to.
Actually, they do talk about it a lot.
They're like, "Be ashamed."
I don't know how we got onto
countries or whatever the fuck,
but I mean, I love talking
about history and countries.
I'm fucking obsessed with history.
I love it so much, but there's
just too much to learn.
- There's just too much.
- I gotta pick an era.
I get so jealous when I meet
people who are like, dude,
"I fucking love the Byzantine era."
And I'm like, "Fuck, dude,
that's just like (indistinct)."
- I heard of that from "Age of Empires".
- I feel like I'm a history buff,
but then someone talks to
me about like ancient Rome
and Egypt and I'm like, "Fuck, I wish
"that was the stuff I was
really interested in."
I just love the past 1000 years history,
even then, that's pushing it.
- I'm the opposite.
I love like the ancient stuff.
- Then you feel like is
your history more better?
Is your history more better?
- More better?
- Is it more significant?
It's like the Romans.
And it's like, "Okay dude,
that's kind of fucking sick."
- You can't go up against that.
- I mean, that's been this
episode of "Trash Taste" I guess.
- Look at all these people.
- Welcome to the America ark.
- Yeah, America ark.
- Let's go!
- Let's welcome all the
patrons as per usual,
Welcome to America guys.
- Yeah, welcome to America.
- How many of them are Americans?
- So the UK ark didn't
actually last that long.
We filmed three episodes,
but literally, we went
to the UK for a wedding
and we somehow got three
episodes out of that,
which is pretty impressive.
- It's probably gonna
be eight plus for this.
- Yeah, we're gonna have a
lot more for the America ark.
- You're gonna see this set for a while
so get used to it.
- And we're gonna have
a lot of guests as well.
- Very exciting guests coming soon.
- So yeah, look forward to that.
Unfortunately, if you
are one of the viewers
that like hearing us shoot shit,
we're gonna go back to that, don't worry.
- We'll figure it out.
- Don't worry, I mean,
you just heard us shoot shit now,
but we have a rare opportunity
where we can get a lot of guests
in a very, very short amount of time
and we wanted to take advantage of that
rather than just waiting
for people to come to fucking Japan,
which we've been waiting for two years.
- God knows when that's gonna happen.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But Hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
go up to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the sub Reddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
And we will see you for
more LA goodness next week.
- I'm sure by the end of this,
we're gonna have so many
America stories, so many.
- Look forward to those, all right, bye.
- Bye.
(mid tempo music)